Hey everybody! This is a super, super exciting episode. using only Python with Meredith Luff. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. This is a super, super exciting episode. I can't tell you how many times I've gone into Google and typed in like Python GUI because as most people know, I do a lot of machine learning. That's my day job. And I do a lot of it on the side too for fun.
大家好！这一期节目非常、非常令人兴奋。我们只用 Python，嘉宾是 Meredith Luff。Jason，交给你了。大家好。这一期节目非常、非常令人兴奋。我数不清自己有多少次打开谷歌，搜索“Python GUI”之类的东西，因为大家都知道，我做了很多机器学习工作。那是我的本职工作，而且我也经常在业余时间做这些，纯粹是为了好玩。
And I always want some way to visualize things. I'm always looking for new ways to do that. And so I'm really excited that we have Meredith here, who's the founder and CEO of Anvil. And he's going to talk to us about how Anvil, how you can use Python kind of all the way through the full stack. So thanks.
我总是想找一种方法来可视化这些内容。我一直在寻找实现这一目标的新方法。所以我很高兴 Meredith 能来到这里，她是 Anvil 的创始人兼首席执行官。他将为我们介绍 Anvil，以及如何全程使用 Python 来构建全栈应用。谢谢。
So glad to have you on the show, Meredith. Thank you very much for having me. Cool. So yeah, there's a lot to unpack here. Why don't you kind of talk about what Anvil is, and then we can dive into a lot of the details. All right. So Anvil is a development environment for building web apps quickly and simply. And it does that by letting you use Python everywhere. So if you jump into the Anvil editor, you'll get a drag and drop UI creator where you can build like component based UIs. And then if you double click a button, now you're editing the Python code that runs in the web browser when you interact with that UI. And then you can also write some server code and build the database and add all sorts of external integrations, user authentication, that sort of thing.
很高兴你能来参加节目，Meredith。非常感谢你的邀请。太棒了。这里有很多内容需要展开。你能不能先介绍一下 Anvil 是什么，然后我们再深入探讨细节。好的。Anvil 是一个用于快速、简单地构建 Web 应用的开发环境。它通过让你在任何地方使用 Python 来实现这一点。如果你进入 Anvil 编辑器，你会看到一个拖拽式的 UI 创建器，可以在其中构建基于组件的界面。当你双击一个按钮时，你就可以编辑在与该 UI 交互时在 Web 浏览器中运行的 Python 代码。此外，你还可以编写服务器端代码、构建数据库，并添加各种外部集成、用户身份验证等功能。
And then, you know, click and publish it in a kind of serverless sort of way. So maybe the best way to think about it is if you think about those old school rapid app dev tools we had like at the end of the desktop era it's like visual basic and delphi it's like that for the web oh i see so so the um if i remember those tools basically you had this kind of whizzy wig like editor and you could kind of drag and draw buttons you double click on them and it kind of takes you to some partially auto-generated code? Yeah, exactly that. So what it means is that you can build your user interface without having to get down and dirty into the HTML and CSS instantly. It's real programming. This is not one of those no-code things because you're actually writing real code in a real programming language, Python, that runs in the browser. We compile that to JavaScript, and we can talk about how we do that later if you like. And then rather than having to
然后，你可以通过一种类似无服务器（serverless）的方式点击发布。也许最好的理解方式是，把它想象成我们在桌面时代末期使用的那些老派快速应用开发工具，比如 Visual Basic 和 Delphi，它就是 Web 端的这些工具。哦，我明白了。如果我没记错的话，那些工具基本上都有一个“所见即所得”的编辑器，你可以拖拽按钮，双击它们，然后它会带你进入一些部分自动生成的代码？是的，完全正确。这意味着你可以立即构建用户界面，而无需深入研究 HTML 和 CSS。这是真正的编程。这不是那种“无代码”工具，因为你实际上是在用一种真正的编程语言——Python——编写真正的代码，并在浏览器中运行。我们将其编译为 JavaScript，如果你愿意，我们稍后可以讨论我们是如何做到这一点的。然后，与其不得不
deal with the HTTP and routing and REST endpoints and all that stuff, you can just say, okay, I'm going to define a Python module, it runs on the server. And then I'm going to tag these functions as something we can call from the browser. So what we've done is we have taken the web stack, which is actually really, really complicated and forbidding. And we've turned that into all one representation. So if you think about an ordinary web application, if you've built these before, if you think about your data, like an ordinary database-backed web application, your data starts out as rows in a table in your database. And then the first thing you do is you take them out and you transform those into objects in your server-side code, whatever language that's in, maybe Python.
处理 HTTP、路由、REST 端点以及所有这些东西，你只需要定义一个在服务器上运行的 Python 模块。然后，将这些函数标记为可以从浏览器调用的函数。所以我们所做的是，我们将 Web 技术栈（实际上非常、非常复杂且令人望而生畏）转化为了统一的表示形式。如果你考虑一个普通的 Web 应用，如果你以前构建过这些，如果你考虑你的数据，比如一个普通的数据库驱动的 Web 应用，你的数据最初是数据库表中一行行的数据。然后你做的第一件事就是把它们取出来，并在你的服务器端代码中将它们转换为对象，无论那是什么语言，可能是 Python。
And then you immediately turn around and represent those objects, which have their own methods and attributes. You turn those into JSON served over HTTP with this really limited set of verbs like get, post, put, delete. And on the other end of that HTTP request is some JavaScript that immediately transforms that JSON into a JavaScript object with its own set of methods, its own set of attributes. And then you turn around and you represent, re-represent that data as HTML DOM. And then you use CSS to re-represent it as pixels. And that is the day-to-day work of web development, is shoveling your data and your application's state between these different representations. And we thought, it's not difficult to work out that this is way, way, way more complicated than it needs to be.
然后你立即转过身来，表示这些拥有自己方法和属性的对象。你将它们转换为通过 HTTP 提供的 JSON，并使用像 GET、POST、PUT、DELETE 这样非常有限的动词集。在那个 HTTP 请求的另一端是一些 JavaScript，它立即将该 JSON 转换为具有自己方法和属性的 JavaScript 对象。然后你转过身来，将这些数据重新表示为 HTML DOM。然后你使用 CSS 将其重新表示为像素。这就是 Web 开发的日常工作，即在这些不同的表示形式之间搬运数据和应用状态。我们认为，不难发现这比它本应有的复杂程度要高得多、多得多。
Have you ever looked at one of those? There's this really great chart on GitHub, like, you know, these are the basic technologies you need to know to be a web developer. And like, it's just like pages and pages and pages and pages of stuff. And it's all kind of wired together, and you need to fit these, you know, 20 different components together. And we thought, well, if it were all just a Python program, if you could just, if getting from the server to the client wasn't a matter of mashing things into JSON, it was a matter of making a function call. If putting something on the screen wasn't a matter of generating source code in one programming language that templates a different markup language that is then transformed into pixels by a third language, and they all kind of work together,
你有没有看过那些图表？GitHub 上有一张非常棒的图表，列出了作为 Web 开发人员需要掌握的基本技术。那简直是好几页、好几页的内容。它们都以某种方式连接在一起，你需要将这 20 种不同的组件拼凑起来。我们想，如果这一切都只是一个 Python 程序呢？如果从服务器到客户端的过程不是把东西塞进 JSON，而是一个函数调用呢？如果把东西显示在屏幕上不是生成一种编程语言的源代码，去模板化另一种标记语言，然后再由第三种语言转换成像素，而且它们还得凑在一起工作，
and you squint and you get something on the screen. If we could replace that by put a button there, and then make its text be such and such. If we could replace the process of standing up a machine on AWS and setting up a web server and setting up the front end and standing up a database with, well, hey, here's this serverless hosting. If we could do all of that, suddenly creating a web application is no more complicated than writing a Python script. And frankly, that's where it should be. There is no reason that the greatest application delivery platform on earth should have the bar set that high for, like, you must know these five different programming languages before you can ride this ride. You must know HTML and JavaScript and CSS and Python and SQL and React and Redux and Bootstrap and Flask and SQL Alchemy. And that's before we've even got to the DevOps stuff. That is not
你眯着眼睛看，最后屏幕上才出现点东西。如果我们能用“把一个按钮放在那里，然后让它的文字变成这样”来代替这一切呢？如果我们能用“嘿，这是无服务器托管”来代替在 AWS 上启动机器、设置 Web 服务器、设置前端和建立数据库的过程呢？如果我们能做到这一切，那么创建一个 Web 应用就不会比编写一个 Python 脚本更复杂。坦率地说，它本该如此。没有理由让地球上最伟大的应用交付平台把门槛设得那么高，要求你必须掌握这五种不同的编程语言才能入门。你必须懂 HTML、JavaScript、CSS、Python、SQL、React、Redux、Bootstrap、Flask 和 SQL Alchemy。而且这还是在 DevOps 之前。这根本
necessary complexity. A web application where you click something and something happens ought to be as simple as writing the equivalent Python script. And we set out to make that happen. Yeah, it totally makes sense. I think a lot of the open source libraries, and this is true in general, but especially for web, they're built by companies that have gigantic websites. I mean, I have websites that are, you know, the code base is enormous and the throughput, the QPS is enormous.
不是必要的复杂性。一个点击一下就会发生某些事情的 Web 应用，应该像编写相应的 Python 脚本一样简单。我们着手让这一切成为现实。是的，这完全说得通。我认为很多开源库，这在一般情况下是正确的，但对于 Web 来说尤其如此，它们是由拥有巨大网站的公司构建的。我的意思是，我有一些网站，代码库非常庞大，吞吐量和 QPS（每秒查询率）也非常高。
And so, yeah, if you have a gigantic, you know, massive organization of people, then it kind of makes sense. You know, we'll have sort of people design a sort of GraphQL server, and that's going to be, you know, whole teams of people working on that. And then there's a whole bunch of other teams of people consuming that. And it's all sort of decentralized, right? But the problem is nothing starts that way, right? Like nobody goes into the first iteration of their company, and they're trying to find product market fit, and they have three customers. And they're, they're, they're like, you know, stressing
所以，是的，如果你有一个庞大的组织，那么这确实有意义。你知道，我们会让一些人设计一个 GraphQL 服务器，那将是整个团队的人在做这件事。然后还有一大堆其他团队的人在使用它。这一切都是去中心化的，对吧？但问题是，没有任何东西是一开始就那样的，对吧？没有人会在公司第一轮迭代时，试图寻找产品市场契合度，只有三个客户的时候，还在那里
about their GraphQL throughput, like, it just doesn't work that way. And there's not that much visualization for people who are, you know, wanting to get started quickly. I totally agree with you. But I would take that analysis even further. Even those huge high throughput guys, the web isn't the architecture they would have chosen. You just mentioned several different technologies that are actually about taking the primitives that the web gives you, which basically they were organic. They kind of grew up over the early 2000s. Now we're stuck with them and turning them into something that these hyperscale people can use. Things like GraphQL is literally a solution to the problem. Oh, wait, REST is not a good way of representing our server-side APIs. Guess we're going to have
为他们的 GraphQL 吞吐量感到压力，事情根本不是那样运作的。而且对于那些想要快速上手的人来说，并没有太多的可视化工具。我完全同意你的观点。但我会把这个分析推得更远。即使是那些高吞吐量的大公司，Web 也不是他们会选择的架构。你刚才提到了几种不同的技术，它们实际上是关于利用 Web 提供的原语，这些原语基本上是有机发展的。它们在 21 世纪初成长起来。现在我们被它们困住了，并试图把它们变成这些超大规模用户可以使用的东西。像 GraphQL 这样的东西，实际上就是解决这个问题的方案。哦，等等，REST 不是表示我们服务器端 API 的好方法。看来我们得
to build something else on top. React is HTML DOM is not a good way of representing our server-side APIs, guess we're going to have to build something else on top. React is HTML DOM is not a good way of representing our UIs, guess we're going to have to build something else on top. All of this stuff is patching over the web, patching upon patches upon patches to try and make it a usable development environment. And that is as true when you are these incredibly high-scale people building funky GraphQL backends as it is if you're a data scientist who just wants to be able to select from a dropdown and then draw the appropriate graph on the screen. Actually, almost everybody who's using the web is suffering from these problems in some respect. Having said which, of course, you're absolutely right that these are the core customers we're starting with first, like the sorts of people
在上面构建别的东西。React 是 HTML DOM 不是表示我们服务器端 API 的好方法，看来我们得在上面构建别的东西。React 是 HTML DOM 不是表示我们 UI 的好方法，看来我们得在上面构建别的东西。所有这些东西都是在给 Web 打补丁，补丁之上再打补丁，试图让它成为一个可用的开发环境。当你是一个构建时髦 GraphQL 后端的超大规模用户时，这和作为一个只想从下拉菜单中选择并绘制相应图表的科学家一样真实。实际上，几乎所有使用 Web 的人都在某种程度上遭受这些问题的困扰。话虽如此，当然，你绝对正确，这些是我们首先要接触的核心客户，比如那些
who go, well, I just want to put a button here and draw a graph on the screen, or I want to prototype my product. And those are the people we can really say, hey, there is in fact a better option. Here's how you can do it 10 times faster. Yeah, it makes sense. I think you really hit the nail on the head that the whole HTTP invention was for just server-side rendering. It's for just dropping almost like a printing press, right? It's sort of like we just give you this sort of structure and you just drop it onto your screen. And then obviously the web is totally different now. Now things are sort of hydrated and the hydration for a lot of websites is everything. Like there's some websites that
会说“我只想在这里放一个按钮并画一个图表，或者我想原型化我的产品”的人。对于这些人，我们真的可以告诉他们：嘿，事实上有一个更好的选择。这是你可以快 10 倍的方法。是的，这说得通。我认为你真的抓住了重点，整个 HTTP 的发明只是为了服务器端渲染。它就像一台印刷机，对吧？它就像是我们给你这种结构，你把它扔到屏幕上。然后显然现在的 Web 完全不同了。现在事物是“水合”的，对于许多网站来说，水合就是一切。有些网站
if you don't have JavaScript on, you just get a blank screen or something, right? Yeah. And there's nothing wrong with that architecture, right? It's just like your classic thick client architecture. You have this runtime so you can have fast responses and fast interactions on the device you're actually using. And then it talks to a server and that server talks to a database. None of that architecture is actually bad. What I would assert is unnecessarily difficult to use is the particular way the web has evolved around that. Because just like, yeah, exactly what you said, because it's evolved over this document-based substrate, it's kind of, at every point, it's done like the minimum required to hack this
如果你不开启 JavaScript，你只会得到一个空白屏幕之类的东西，对吧？是的。这种架构本身没什么问题，对吧？它就像经典的胖客户端架构。你拥有这个运行时，所以你可以在你实际使用的设备上获得快速的响应和交互。然后它与服务器通信，服务器与数据库通信。这些架构本身并不坏。我要断言的是，Web 围绕它演变出的特定方式是不必要地难以使用。因为就像你说的，因为它是在这种基于文档的基底上演变的，它在每一点上都做了最少量的黑客式处理，以添加
next piece of functionality on. And so you end up with this mess that's really, really difficult to approach. And, you know, there's no reason that a beginner or a data scientist or someone whose experience is somewhere else, like, you know, manufacturing engineer should have to learn all this amount of stuff just to be able to, you know, produce an interactive screen. Yeah, exactly. I think, you know, this is even true for, and this is going to be a bit of a tangent, it was even true for desktop. I think this is one of the reasons why, you know, at least for data science, you know, this Jupyter notebook has been so popular because, you know, it took all the painstaking time and effort to do that. But then you're kind of limited to whatever
下一项功能。所以你最终得到的是一个非常、非常难以接近的烂摊子。而且，你知道，没有理由让初学者、数据科学家或经验在其他领域的人（比如制造工程师）必须学习这么多东西，才能产生一个交互式屏幕。是的，完全正确。我认为，你知道，这甚至适用于——这会有点跑题——它甚至适用于桌面端。我认为这就是为什么，至少对于数据科学来说，Jupyter Notebook 如此受欢迎的原因，因为它省去了所有费时费力的工作。但随后你又受限于
supported, you know, by Jupyter. Ideally, you would have, as Anvil is, a programming environment which is much more open-ended. Well, funny you should mention that, actually. Because yes, absolutely. Jupyter is a fantastic piece of technology. And the way that it's got back this kind of cell-based interactive programming is a really great fit for a lot of data science tasks.
Jupyter 支持的任何东西。理想情况下，你会拥有像 Anvil 这样的编程环境，它更加开放。嗯，你提到这个很有趣。因为是的，绝对是这样。Jupyter 是一项出色的技术。它所拥有的这种基于单元格的交互式编程方式，对于许多数据科学任务来说非常契合。
But as you say, it's fundamentally just a Python script. And so there's limits to what you can do in terms of interactivity. We actually have a library that can connect a Jupyter notebook to an Anvil UI. So because this is a problem, again, that keeps recurring, because there are a lot of problems for which actually, you know, just writing a Python script is the right answer. And then you go, oh, well, true, but I would like to connect this to a web UI. So in your machine learning work, I'm sure you will have done a lot of this, right? You are in there, you've got your nose in a Jupyter notebook, you are training, designing, training, refining a model. And then you go, okay, okay like i've got this thing working i'm at the point where
但正如你所说，它本质上只是一个 Python 脚本。因此，在交互性方面你能做的事情是有限的。我们实际上有一个库可以将 Jupyter Notebook 连接到 Anvil UI。因为这是一个反复出现的问题，因为有很多问题，实际上，只写一个 Python 脚本就是正确的答案。然后你会说，哦，好吧，确实，但我希望将其连接到 Web UI。所以在你的机器学习工作中，我相信你一定做过很多这样的事情，对吧？你在那里，你埋头于 Jupyter Notebook，你在训练、设计、训练、优化模型。然后你说，好吧，我已经让这个东西工作了，我已经到了
actually i've gone as far as i want to go by interactively typing python into a programming environment now i want someone else to be able to use it i would like to you know be able to put some interactive visualization on it i'd like to stick it up there so you know i've got an image recognizer and i'd like someone else to be able to come along and take a picture with their mobile phone or upload something from their computer. And what we've actually got is something called the uplink, which is a library you can pip install anywhere you're running a Python script. And it makes a connection up to the Anvil servers. And then your Python interpreter, wherever it is, say inside your Jupyter notebook, it's like it's part of that app. So you can access the data tables in your Anvil app with exactly the same API as you could if you were running in our serverless environment.
实际上，通过在编程环境中交互式地输入 Python，我已经走得足够远了，现在我希望别人也能使用它。我希望能够放一些交互式可视化在上面，我想把它发布出去，所以我有一个图像识别器，我希望别人能够走过来，用他们的手机拍一张照片，或者从他们的电脑上传一些东西。我们实际上有一个叫做 Uplink 的东西，这是一个你可以在任何运行 Python 脚本的地方通过 pip 安装的库。它会建立一个到 Anvil 服务器的连接。然后你的 Python 解释器，无论它在哪里，比如在你的 Jupyter Notebook 内部，就像它是那个应用的一部分一样。所以你可以用和在我们的无服务器环境中运行完全相同的 API 来访问 Anvil 应用中的数据表。
You can call functions in that serverless environment. You can even define those callable functions that can be called from the webpage. So, we have a neat demo, perhaps we can drop a link in the show notes, of taking a Jupyter notebook that does an image recognition task, and then going, well, okay, now I want to turn this into a web app, import the library, take the function that takes an image and returns the classification, tag it as, hey, this is a function we want to be callable from the browser. And then just going into the browser, having a file uploader, when a file gets uploaded into that widget, anvil.server.call, classify image, pass the file in and get the return value. It's just a function call. It's just Python. It just works. So yeah, we have something for that.
你可以调用那个无服务器环境中的函数。你甚至可以定义那些可以从网页调用的可调用函数。所以，我们有一个很棒的演示，也许我们可以在节目笔记中放一个链接，展示如何获取一个执行图像识别任务的 Jupyter Notebook，然后说，好吧，现在我想把它变成一个 Web 应用，导入库，获取那个接收图像并返回分类的函数，将其标记为“嘿，这是一个我们希望从浏览器调用的函数”。然后只需进入浏览器，拥有一个文件上传器，当文件上传到该小部件时，调用 anvil.server.call，classify_image，传入文件并获取返回值。这只是一个函数调用。这只是 Python。它就是能用。所以是的，我们有针对这种情况的方案。
Yeah. Yeah. I think that that makes a ton of sense. So I'm trying to think like, I think you did a good job explaining kind of the sort of traditional web development, right? And just just to kind of reiterate, actually, I didn't really explain what GraphQL is, and rest. So let me cover a bit of terminology. And then we can dive into into how Anvil, you know, works, right? Yeah, so typically, if you're on a website, your browser's running this engine called JavaScript. Programmers can go in and write things like change colors of buttons, add content that wasn't there before, things like that. And the way that it does that is by running this JavaScript engine in your browser, but
是的。是的。我认为这非常有道理。所以我试着想，我觉得你很好地解释了传统的 Web 开发，对吧？为了重申一下，实际上，我并没有真正解释什么是 GraphQL 和 REST。所以让我涵盖一些术语。然后我们可以深入探讨 Anvil 是如何工作的，对吧？是的，通常如果你在一个网站上，你的浏览器正在运行这个叫 JavaScript 的引擎。程序员可以进去编写一些东西，比如改变按钮颜色、添加之前不存在的内容等等。它实现这一点的方式是在你的浏览器中运行这个 JavaScript 引擎，但
often it needs to go back to the server and get more information, right? Maybe someone sends you a message and you have some, you know, IM thing on your, some IM website that needs to be interactive. So, you know, it's constantly going to the server and saying, hey, is there something new that I need to know about? And the way it does that is by basically visiting websites that are just meant to return data. So if you go to google.com, you're going to get this rendering, but there are other websites. If you go to them, you're just going to get a batch of data. And most of the time, people are doing JSON as the transport. So you're going to get some actually human readable, I guess. I mean, it's usually like a mess, but you're going to get something in characters that
通常它需要回到服务器获取更多信息，对吧？也许有人给你发了一条消息，你有一些 IM 工具在你的 IM 网站上，需要是交互式的。所以，它不断地去服务器询问，嘿，有什么我需要知道的新东西吗？它实现这一点的方式基本上是访问那些只打算返回数据的网站。所以如果你去 google.com，你会得到这种渲染，但还有其他网站。如果你去访问它们，你只会得到一批数据。大多数时候，人们使用 JSON 作为传输格式。所以你会得到一些实际上人类可读的，我想是这样。我的意思是，它通常是一团糟，但你会得到一些字符，
you can see that's going to represent some structured information, right? And so if you were to build a, you know, let's say, I don't know, old school, if you were to build an old school kind of interactive website, you would have a bunch of, you'd have your main website, you know, mycoolwebsite.com slash, you know, index.html. But then you'd also have, and you'd also have your images and all of that. Each of those would be URLs and the server would know where to go to get those. And then you'd have all these other URLs that just return data. And presumably they have logic behind them. So they're going to return different data when you call them, depending on the context. There's something else called cookies,
你可以看到这些字符代表了一些结构化信息，对吧？所以如果你要构建一个，我不知道，老派的，如果你要构建一个老派的交互式网站，你会有一堆，你会拥有你的主网站，mycoolwebsite.com/index.html。但你也会有，你也会有你的图片和所有这些。每一个都会是 URL，服务器会知道去哪里获取它们。然后你会有所有这些只返回数据的其他 URL。据推测，它们背后有逻辑。所以当你调用它们时，根据上下文，它们会返回不同的数据。还有别的东西叫 cookies，
which is think of cookies as like a really small database that your computer and the server are sharing for your connection. And so the cookies are a way so that when you go from one page to the next, you're still logged in every time. But this was a huge pain. It's like I have to make a URL for every piece of data I need. Like, give me the current time. Tell me how many friends I have. Tell me all my friends' names. Well, and crucially, when you clicked to go from one of those things to the other,
你可以把 cookies 想象成你的电脑和服务器为你的连接共享的一个非常小的数据库。所以 cookies 是一种方式，这样当你从一个页面转到下一个页面时，你每次仍然是登录状态。但这非常痛苦。就像我需要为我需要的每一条数据创建一个 URL。比如，给我当前时间。告诉我我有多少朋友。告诉我我所有朋友的名字。嗯，而且至关重要的是，当你点击从其中一个东西转到另一个东西时，
your whole page refreshed. You were staring at a little bit of white screen while the next whole page downloaded. Then it showed the next whole page to you. And the web was advancing and we wanted to be more interactive. Yeah, that's so true. So then we get to the sort of single page apps where, you know, it's even fetching not only just data and HTML, but it's actually kind of fetching new HTML and kind of building as it goes. And then, but you're having all these URLs just because it becomes really cluttered. So this GraphQL was this idea that let's just have one URL,
你的整个页面都会刷新。你盯着一点点白屏，同时下载下一个完整的页面。然后它向你展示下一个完整的页面。Web 正在进步，我们希望更具交互性。是的，这太对了。所以我们到了单页应用，你知道，它不仅获取数据和 HTML，它实际上是在获取新的 HTML 并边走边构建。但是，你拥有所有这些 URL，只是因为它们变得非常杂乱。所以这个 GraphQL 的想法是，让我们只有一个 URL，
but you'll pass in, you know, a specification that says what you need. Kind of like when you, you know, write SQL queries, there's only one SQL engine and the query just tells the engine to do different things. So with GraphQL, there's only one URL that you go to for all your data. But by passing in different, almost like different queries,
但你会传入一个说明你需要的规范。就像当你编写 SQL 查询时，只有一个 SQL 引擎，查询只是告诉引擎做不同的事情。所以对于 GraphQL，你访问所有数据只有一个 URL。但是通过传入不同的，几乎像不同的查询，
you're going to get back different pieces of information. And so that was better, but it still has this challenge that Meredith talked about where GraphQL does everything in this thing called JSON. And so if you want to pass an image, for example, in GraphQL, you actually have to convert that image into letters and then send it to the client and then turn it back. And so it just becomes a huge hassle to represent everything in this way and then just to turn it back into something that you're going to render well and also the the fundamental structure of a web application is that your browser goes to a site and your site serves up the source code for
你会得到不同的信息。所以这更好，但它仍然有 Meredith 谈到的挑战，即 GraphQL 在这个叫 JSON 的东西里做所有事情。所以如果你想在 GraphQL 中传递一张图片，例如，你实际上必须将该图片转换为字母，然后发送给客户端，然后再转回来。所以以这种方式表示所有东西，然后再转回你将要渲染的东西，就变成了一个巨大的麻烦。而且 Web 应用的基本结构是你的浏览器访问一个站点，你的站点提供源代码，
an app that will run in your browser this is is how it mostly works these days. And then the browser is running an application that's built with JavaScript and HTML. And then when that app running in your browser wants to get some kind of data from the server, it will make an HTTP request to the server. And there are various conventions for how we use those requests to get data instead of HTML. There's sort of, you could have a URL for everything, which is the REST pattern, or you can have something like a GraphQL where you have one URL that you post this complicated query to, and it gives you back some complicated response. But all of this is being squeezed over HTTP requests, which is exactly the same thing that your browser is using to fetch the
一个将在你的浏览器中运行的应用，这就是现在大多数情况下的工作方式。然后浏览器运行一个用 JavaScript 和 HTML 构建的应用。然后当你在浏览器中运行的应用想要从服务器获取某种数据时，它会向服务器发出 HTTP 请求。有各种约定来使用这些请求获取数据而不是 HTML。有一种，你可以为每件事都有一个 URL，这就是 REST 模式，或者你可以有像 GraphQL 这样的东西，你有一个 URL，你向它发布这个复杂的查询，它会给你返回一些复杂的响应。但所有这些都被挤压在 HTTP 请求上，这和你浏览器用来获取
web page in the first place. And HTTP is a great protocol for fetching web pages. It's not necessarily a great protocol for doing what your application actually wants to do, which is that the part of your code that's running in the web browser wants to talk to the part of your code that's running on the server and do something that's, well, do something that's part of your application. And if this were an old school desktop application, you'd just make a function call. And you'd be modular and expose a certain API. Oh yes, the GUI section calls the backend engine for these things. And these days on the web,
网页的协议是一样的。HTTP 是获取网页的绝佳协议。它不一定是做你应用实际想做的事情的绝佳协议，即你运行在 Web 浏览器中的那部分代码想要与运行在服务器上的那部分代码对话，并做一些事情，嗯，做一些作为你应用一部分的事情。如果这是一个老派的桌面应用，你只需要进行函数调用。而且你会是模块化的，并暴露特定的 API。哦，是的，GUI 部分调用后端引擎来处理这些事情。而现在在 Web 上，
whether you use something like REST or whether you use something like GraphQL, you're kind of twisting the way your app thinks about the world until it's shaped like the way that HTTP thinks about the world. And that's just an amount of stress that as a programmer you don't need. And this is why in Anvil we have,
无论你使用像 REST 还是 GraphQL 这样的东西，你都在扭曲你的应用看待世界的方式，直到它被塑造成 HTTP 看待世界的方式。这只是作为程序员你不需要承受的压力。这就是为什么在 Anvil 中我们有，
you can still use those. So if you already have an API that's built in REST or GraphQL, you could absolutely use it with the standard HTTP stuff. But the usual way of communicating between the bit of your app that's running in the user's web browser and the bit of the app that's running on the server is just to make a function call.
你仍然可以使用那些。所以如果你已经有一个用 REST 或 GraphQL 构建的 API，你绝对可以使用标准的 HTTP 内容。但你的应用运行在用户 Web 浏览器中的部分与运行在服务器上的部分之间进行通信的通常方式，只是进行函数调用。
And you can pass arguments to that function call. You can get return values to that function call. Unlike a classic JSON API request, you're not limited to just dictionaries and strings and numbers and lists. You can, I mean, in the image recognition example, you can just pass a blob of binary data that was uploaded as a file from the computer. You can just pass that as an argument to the function and Anvil takes care of taking all that large lump of binary bytes from your browser to the server and putting it into a form that your server-side code can easily
你可以向该函数调用传递参数。你可以获得该函数调用的返回值。与经典的 JSON API 请求不同，你不局限于字典、字符串、数字和列表。你可以，我的意思是，在图像识别示例中，你可以只传递一个作为文件从电脑上传的二进制数据块。你可以只将其作为参数传递给函数，Anvil 会负责将所有这些来自浏览器的二进制字节大块发送到服务器，并将其放入你的服务器端代码可以轻松
deal with. And this is just one example of how twisting your application's logic into the shape that the web stack expects is just making you do unnecessary work. And we've done the same in the client, where instead of generating HTML, which is kind of programming language all of its own, you can say, well, actually, the thing I want to do is I want to add a UI component. And so we have this object oriented thing where you could just construct an object in Python. You could construct a button object, set its button one dot text equals blah, self dot add component button and put a button on the screen. And that's, again, it's not making you twist what your application is doing into the shape of what the web platform is expecting. And so that is, I think, the crucial theme that runs all the way through
处理的形式中。这只是将你的应用逻辑扭曲成 Web 技术栈所期望的形状是如何让你做不必要工作的众多例子之一。我们在客户端也做了同样的事情，与其生成 HTML（它本身就是一种编程语言），你可以说，嗯，实际上，我想做的是添加一个 UI 组件。所以我们有这个面向对象的东西，你可以只在 Python 中构造一个对象。你可以构造一个按钮对象，设置它的 button1.text 等于 blah，self.add_component(button) 并把一个按钮放在屏幕上。这再次说明，它没有让你把你的应用正在做的事情扭曲成 Web 平台所期望的形状。所以我认为，这是贯穿
AML's architecture from top to bottom. And doing function calls instead of REST or GraphQL is just one example of that. Yeah, it totally makes sense. I think too, if there's this extra benefit where if you're already using Python for a task, if you have some Python program and you want people to see it on the web, or you want to write a web visualizer, then without using Anvil, everything you want to see has to be represented in JavaScript. So now it's like you have to have sort of your Python representation of all this knowledge. And then you have to have this JavaScript representation, and you have to constantly be converting from one to the other.
Anvil 架构从上到下的关键主题。进行函数调用而不是 REST 或 GraphQL 只是其中的一个例子。是的，这完全说得通。我认为如果还有这个额外的好处，如果你已经在使用 Python 进行任务，如果你有一些 Python 程序，你想让人们在 Web 上看到它，或者你想写一个 Web 可视化工具，那么如果不使用 Anvil，你想要看到的一切都必须用 JavaScript 表示。所以现在就像你必须拥有所有这些知识的 Python 表示。然后你必须拥有这个 JavaScript 表示，并且你必须不断地在两者之间进行转换。
And so, yeah, that ends up taking a huge amount of time. And it can actually be really difficult. I mean, JavaScript wasn't designed to handle binary data. Now they have a whole bunch of cool things for it. So, I mean, it's definitely evolved to meet the demand. But yeah, it's evolved rather than being designed is sort of the point. Exactly. But yes, exactly that.
所以，是的，这最终会花费大量的时间。而且它实际上可能非常困难。我的意思是，JavaScript 并不是为了处理二进制数据而设计的。现在他们有很多很酷的东西来处理它。所以，我的意思是，它绝对是为了满足需求而演变的。但是的，重点是它是演变的，而不是被设计的。完全正确。但是的，完全就是那样。
So yeah, let's dive into the magic here. I mean, it seems pretty magical that someone, you know, we just told people that you can only write JavaScript in the browser. So somebody, you know, so someone's writing some Python. And so I think you said that they're annotating some functions and saying, oh, these are server endpoints. And I guess there's maybe like some Python files that are running in the browser.
所以，让我们深入了解这里的魔法。我的意思是，有人告诉人们你只能在浏览器中写 JavaScript，这看起来很神奇。所以有人，你知道，有人在写一些 Python。所以我认为你说他们正在注释一些函数并说，哦，这些是服务器端点。我想也许有一些 Python 文件在浏览器中运行。
Some are running on the server. Like how does all of that come together? All right, yeah. So here's what happens. When you open the Anvil editor, you've got, you know, it's a standard IDE type layout. You've got a list down the left of your modules. And there are two sorts. There are client modules, and then there are server modules. And whenever you're editing client code, which
有些在服务器上运行。这一切是如何结合在一起的？好的，是的。这就是发生的事情。当你打开 Anvil 编辑器时，你拥有，你知道，这是一个标准的 IDE 类型布局。你的左侧有一个模块列表。有两种类型。有客户端模块，还有服务器模块。每当你编辑客户端代码时，这
includes these pieces of a user interface that can appear on your page, there are also client side Python modules. They're just Python classes, actually. Everything is a Python object. We try not to be magical about this part. But when you write code that runs on the client, Anvil will actually translate that from Python to JavaScript. So when someone visits your application, what they load is actually a Python runtime written in JavaScript. It's called Sculpt, S-K-U-L-P-T. It's a really cool open source project. We contribute heavily to it. And that is the kind of the translator that allows you to run your, turns your Python code into JavaScript code that does the same thing. And so when you click on that button, what's actually happening is that a JavaScript function is running, but that JavaScript function
包括可以出现在你页面上的用户界面部分，还有客户端 Python 模块。它们实际上只是 Python 类。一切都是 Python 对象。我们尽量不对这部分进行魔法处理。但当你编写在客户端运行的代码时，Anvil 实际上会将其从 Python 翻译成 JavaScript。所以当有人访问你的应用时，他们加载的实际上是一个用 JavaScript 编写的 Python 运行时。它叫 Sculpt，S-K-U-L-P-T。这是一个非常酷的开源项目。我们为它贡献了很多。这就是那种允许你运行你的，将你的 Python 代码转换为做同样事情的 JavaScript 代码的翻译器。所以当你点击那个按钮时，实际发生的是一个 JavaScript 函数正在运行，但那个 JavaScript 函数
was created from the Python code you wrote. And when you call something that's on the server, so you say, if you do anvil.server.call, which is our library function for this, that's Anvil's queue to send a message to the server. And it then goes and talks to Anvil servers, which then spin up your server modules, which are the Python modules that you created in the section that's, no, this doesn't get sent to the web browser. This only executes on the server and loads all of those modules. And then any functions that you have annotated with at anvil.server.callable are accessible. And so when the request comes in and says, I want to call the classify image function, then we look up and say, yes, there's a function called classify image. Yes, it's tagged as accessible. So we run that function. And then when that
是从你编写的 Python 代码创建的。当你调用服务器上的东西时，所以你说，如果你做 anvil.server.call，这是我们为此提供的库函数，那是 Anvil 发送消息到服务器的信号。然后它去与 Anvil 服务器通信，服务器随后启动你的服务器模块，这些是你创建的 Python 模块，在这一部分，不，这不会被发送到 Web 浏览器。这只在服务器上执行并加载所有这些模块。然后任何你用 @anvil.server.callable 注释的函数都是可访问的。所以当请求进来并说，我想调用 classify_image 函数时，我们查找并说，是的，有一个叫 classify_image 的函数。是的，它被标记为可访问。所以我们运行那个函数。然后当那个
function returns something, we will send a message back to the browser saying this function has completed and here was its return value. And the Python code that's running in the browser gets that as the return value from anvil.server.call. I see. I think I get, so let me, let me see if I can reiterate it and I'll, that'll figure out if, isn't that one of the, what's the, what do they call that? They say, if you can reiterate something, then you understand. I don't remember the word for that. But yeah, so... Okay, so the idea is...
函数返回某些东西时，我们会发送一条消息回浏览器，说这个函数已经完成，这是它的返回值。而在浏览器中运行的 Python 代码会将其作为 anvil.server.call 的返回值接收。我明白了。我想我明白了，所以让我，让我看看我是否能重申一下，我会弄清楚，这不是其中之一，什么，他们怎么称呼那个？他们说，如果你能重申某事，那么你就理解了。我不记得那个词了。但是的，所以……好的，所以想法是……
Actually, so what is getting sent to the client then? Is it Python files that then are being executed by this virtual machine? Or is it being compiled somehow? So it is actually... What gets sent to the browser is a Python source code and a Python to JavaScript compiler and runtime. So it actually gets compiled when it's opened in your user's browser.
实际上，那么发送到客户端的是什么？是 Python 文件，然后由这个虚拟机执行吗？还是以某种方式编译的？所以它实际上是……发送到浏览器的是 Python 源代码和一个 Python 到 JavaScript 的编译器和运行时。所以它实际上是在你用户的浏览器中打开时被编译的。
Okay, what's the reason for that? Like what's the reason for not compiling its server side? Oh, I see. That is a speed optimization that we will make at some point. Remarkably, actually, when we profile it, that's not our current limiting factor in terms of performance. So one day we will compile it ahead of time and just serve up the compiled JavaScript when your user accesses your app. We just haven't got there yet.
好的，那是什么原因？比如不进行服务器端编译的原因是什么？哦，我明白了。那是一个我们会在某个时候做的速度优化。值得注意的是，实际上，当我们对其进行分析时，那并不是我们目前在性能方面的限制因素。所以有一天我们会提前编译它，并在你的用户访问你的应用时直接提供编译后的 JavaScript。我们只是还没做到那一步。
Got it. Okay. Makes sense. Since it's compiled on the client side, can people write Python interactively then? So people can write Python fairly interactively. We don't have an interactive Python console in the Anvil editor yet, but watch this space. Actually, by the time this episode goes out, we might have that interactive console might be released. Very cool. Okay. But yes, if you go to sculpt.org, you can actually get a demo of the Sculpt Python JavaScript compiler. And that is like a live Python console
明白了。好的。说得通。既然是在客户端编译的，那么人们可以交互式地编写 Python 吗？所以人们可以相当交互式地编写 Python。我们还没有在 Anvil 编辑器中提供交互式 Python 控制台，但请拭目以待。实际上，到这期节目发布时，我们可能已经发布了那个交互式控制台。非常酷。好的。但是的，如果你去 sculpt.org，你实际上可以得到一个 Sculpt Python JavaScript 编译器的演示。那就像一个实时的 Python 控制台
running in your web browser. It is very cool. Wow, it's amazing. And so they actually wrote a Python VM in JavaScript, like from scratch. Believe it or not, they did. And they're not even the only ones. There are about five different projects, I think, that have tried to put Python in the browser.
在你的 Web 浏览器中运行。它非常酷。哇，太神奇了。所以他们实际上是从零开始用 JavaScript 写了一个 Python 虚拟机。信不信由你，他们确实做到了。而且他们甚至不是唯一这样做的人。我想大约有五个不同的项目试图把 Python 放到浏览器中。
And there are really good reasons for this, because a whole bunch of people who are used to the ease of using Python have looked at the web and gone, oh my goodness, this needs to be simpler. How can we make it simpler? Well, I find Python really easy to write. Let's make it so you can run Python in the web browser. And there's a few of these. So there's something called Brython, which is, it kind of replaces JavaScript with Python. So you still write your script tags in your HTML, which is where you'd normally put your JavaScript, but you write them in Python and then the Brython compiler jumps in and compiles them to JavaScript and executes that JavaScript instead. You've got, there is something called transcript, which is,
而且这样做有非常好的理由，因为一大群习惯了使用 Python 的简便性的人看着 Web 说，哦，天哪，这需要更简单。我们怎样才能让它更简单？嗯，我发现 Python 写起来非常容易。让我们让它可以在 Web 浏览器中运行 Python。这里有几个这样的项目。所以有一个叫 Brython 的东西，它是，它用 Python 替换了 JavaScript。所以你仍然在 HTML 中编写脚本标签，这通常是你放置 JavaScript 的地方，但你用 Python 编写它们，然后 Brython 编译器介入并将它们编译为 JavaScript 并执行该 JavaScript。你有，有一个叫 Transcrypt 的东西，它是，
it compiles something that's mostly Python. It doesn't quite behave exactly like Python, but it compiles it into really clean and fast JavaScript. And that happens ahead of time. So you feed it a bunch of.py files and it generates a bunch of.js files, and then you load those.js files in your web application just as normal. And that's kind of cool, although it doesn't really have a particularly good fidelity to exactly how Python behaves. Like if you're used to, you know, messing around with objects at a low level, then that's not going to work for you. There's also a really cool project called Pyodide, which is out of Mozilla. And that has taken the, rather than writing a new Python VM in JavaScript, it's taken CPython, the standard Python interpreter and compiled it to WebAssembly, which is a kind of fast compiled virtual machine that runs in your browser. And so if you go to the Pyodide page, you can get something that's kind of like a Jupyter notebook. And it's got all these standard data science libraries,
它编译一些主要是 Python 的东西。它的行为并不完全像 Python，但它将其编译成非常干净和快速的 JavaScript。而且这是提前完成的。所以你给它一堆 .py 文件，它生成一堆 .js 文件，然后你像往常一样在你的 Web 应用中加载这些 .js 文件。这很酷，尽管它在 Python 行为的精确保真度方面并不是特别好。比如如果你习惯于，你知道，在底层摆弄对象，那么这对你来说是行不通的。还有一个非常酷的项目叫 Pyodide，它来自 Mozilla。它采取了，而不是用 JavaScript 编写一个新的 Python 虚拟机，它采用了 CPython，标准的 Python 解释器，并将其编译为 WebAssembly，这是一种在你的浏览器中运行的快速编译虚拟机。所以如果你去 Pyodide 页面，你可以得到一些类似于 Jupyter Notebook 的东西。而且它拥有所有这些标准的数据科学库，
only it's running in your browser. It's mind bending. What is that one called? Pyodide, P-Y-O-D-I-D-E. Wow. So they ran the entire Python source code through Nscripten or something? The entire Python source code and a bunch of the classic libraries. I think you can actually use TensorFlow in your web browser. It's nuts. Wow. Amazing. I mean, of course, it takes like a minute to start because it's downloading the entire Python ecosystem when you open the page in the web browser. So it's not going to be that great as an application delivery platform, which is what we're looking for Anvil for. But as a technological achievement, it is spectacular. Yeah, I wonder if that can be cached somehow. So this gets starting to get to my limits on what I know about the web. But I think there's like CDNs that cache things or something, right?
只是它是在你的浏览器中运行的。这太令人难以置信了。那个叫什么名字？Pyodide，P-Y-O-D-I-D-E。哇。所以他们把整个 Python 源代码通过 Emscripten 之类的工具进行了转换？整个 Python 源代码和一大堆经典库。我想你甚至可以在网页浏览器里使用 TensorFlow。这太疯狂了。哇。太棒了。我的意思是，当然，它启动需要一分钟左右，因为它在你在浏览器中打开页面时正在下载整个 Python 生态系统。所以作为应用程序交付平台，它不会太好用，而这正是我们寻找 Anvil 的原因。但作为一项技术成就，它非常壮观。是的，我不知道那东西能不能缓存。这开始触及我对网络知识的极限了。但我认为有类似 CDN 之类的东西可以缓存内容，对吧？
Is there any way to speed that up? There are ways to speed it up. And you could, if you really worked at it, you could get it down from that many seconds to only only a couple of seconds, but it's never going to be like an instant snappy response. Got it. So it's great for what it is, which is loading a Python environment in your browser where you're okay with it taking a few seconds to start up, but it's not going to replace JavaScript for what JavaScript is really used for, which is driving the page in your browser and making it interactive. Yeah, totally makes sense. Okay, so someone goes to the website, they get the default HTML, you know, that whatever hasn't been hydrated yet. So whatever the server is rendered,
有什么办法能加快速度吗？是有办法加快速度的。如果你真的下功夫，你可以把它从那么多秒缩短到只有几秒钟，但它永远不会像即时响应那样快。明白了。所以它非常适合它的定位，即在浏览器中加载一个 Python 环境，如果你能接受它需要几秒钟启动的话，但它不会取代 JavaScript 的核心用途，即驱动浏览器页面并使其具有交互性。是的，完全有道理。好的，所以有人访问网站，他们得到了默认的 HTML，你知道，就是那些还没被“注水”（hydration）的内容。所以无论服务器渲染了什么，
and they get a bunch of py files, and they get this virtual machine. So they grab the virtual machine, they grab the py files, they run the py files through the virtual machine. So they grab the virtual machine, they grab the Py files, they run the Py files through the virtual machine, and that executes some logic. And then part of that logic says things like, call this function on the server. You're on the client, you don't have that function, but there's some way where it knows to take the arguments, I guess, pickle them on, there's like maybe a pickle in the browser. It's kind of like that, yes.
他们会得到一堆 py 文件，还会得到这个虚拟机。所以他们获取虚拟机，获取 py 文件，然后通过虚拟机运行这些 py 文件。所以他们获取虚拟机，获取 py 文件，通过虚拟机运行 py 文件，然后执行一些逻辑。接着那部分逻辑会说类似“在服务器上调用此函数”之类的话。你在客户端，你没有那个函数，但它有一种方法知道如何获取参数，我想，可能是把它们序列化（pickle），也许浏览器里有个 pickle？有点像那样，是的。
Yeah, okay. So the server runs, the server, you know, unpickles it. Pickle is just, by the way, if people don't know, it's just a serialization library in Python. So the server, you know, deserializes it back to those objects, executes the function on the server,
是的，好的。所以服务器运行，服务器，你知道，反序列化它。顺便说一下，如果有人不知道，Pickle 只是 Python 中的一个序列化库。所以服务器，你知道，把它反序列化回那些对象，在服务器上执行函数，
you know, packages up the return value, sends it back to the client. And so the client then keeps going. Is there support for asynchronous calls? There has to be, right? Otherwise it'd be kind of stutters, right? Watch this space. In short, we're working on that on an ongoing basis. But actually, so when you make a call that takes a long time, it doesn't freeze the browser, but you do get a loading spinner, which is just like you get with most other web applications while they're loading some data from the server. We started with this synchronous programming model where you call a function, then you get a return value, and then you carry on executing.
你知道，打包返回值，把它发回给客户端。然后客户端继续运行。支持异步调用吗？肯定有吧，对吧？否则它会卡顿，对吧？敬请期待。简而言之，我们正在持续进行这项工作。但实际上，当你进行一个耗时很长的调用时，它不会冻结浏览器，但你会看到一个加载转圈，就像大多数其他 Web 应用程序在从服务器加载数据时一样。我们从这种同步编程模型开始，你调用一个函数，然后得到一个返回值，然后继续执行。
Because actually, that is what most people want most of the time. Yep. Yep. And one of the reasons, one of the things that makes JavaScript so unfriendly to use is that it's not like that. Its default mode is asynchronous, where you say, well, do this task, make this request to a web server, do this other thing, and then call this other function when you're done. And so you end up kind of daisy chaining, pretty simple, what would otherwise be pretty simple logic, like, okay, well, they've clicked the button, call this function, then call that function, then do the other. You end up like daisy chaining them with a series of callbacks. And then you have syntactic sugar, like as async await if people are familiar with that with
因为实际上，这才是大多数人大多数时候想要的。是的。是的。而且 JavaScript 使用起来不友好的原因之一，就是它不是那样的。它的默认模式是异步的，你会说，好吧，做这个任务，向 Web 服务器发出这个请求，做这个其他事情，然后在完成后调用另一个函数。所以你最终会把本来很简单的逻辑，比如“好的，他们点击了按钮，调用这个函数，然后调用那个函数，然后做其他事”，用一系列回调函数串联起来。然后你有像 async await 这样的语法糖，如果人们熟悉 JavaScript 的话，
javascript but what that is is actually just syntax for daisy trading a set of functions and you still end up if you want to use something like async await at an advanced level you end up still needing to know oh this is producing a promise, and this promise object will invoke its callbacks if you do such and such. And that's, again, an example of the problems caused by, well, we, you know, building this application delivery system out of kind of the bits and pieces we had lying around in a web browser. And so we wanted to start with this very straightforward programming model where if you wanted to get something from the server, you could do, you know, x equals, call this function, and then use x on the next line of code without having to understand everything about async programming in order to get
但那实际上只是串联一组函数的语法。如果你想在高级层面使用 async await，你仍然需要知道“哦，这会产生一个 Promise，如果你做了这样那样的事，这个 Promise 对象就会调用它的回调”。这又是一个例子，说明了我们试图用在浏览器里随手捡来的零碎东西构建这个应用程序交付系统所带来的问题。所以我们想从这种非常直接的编程模型开始，如果你想从服务器获取东西，你可以写“x 等于，调用这个函数”，然后在下一行代码中使用 x，而无需为了让“Hello World”运行起来而去理解关于异步编程的一切。我明白了。我想这之所以能行是因为有虚拟机，对吧？所以我想，如果我错了请纠正我，但在 JavaScript 中，我相当确定机器是单线程的。所以实际上，有 Web Workers，但我们先不谈那个。所以基本上，你确实需要一切都是异步的，因为你一次只能执行一行代码。如果那一行在等待服务器返回，那么其他事情就无法完成。但在这里，因为你有这个虚拟机，我不认为你受到这种限制，对吧？绝对正确。我实际上在 2017 年的 PyCon 上做过一次闪电演讲。如果你的节目笔记里还有空间，我会把链接发给你，我在那里拆解了 Sculpt 编译器，
Hello World to work. I see it. I think that works because of the VM, right? So I think, correct me if I'm wrong, but with JavaScript, I'm pretty sure the machine is only single threaded. So actually, there are web workers, but we'll put that aside. So basically, you kind of need everything to be asynchronous, because you can only be executing one line of code at a time. And if that line is waiting for the server to come back, then nothing else can get done. But here, because you have this VM, I don't think you're limited in this way, right? Absolutely. I actually gave a lightning talk at PyCon in 2017. And if you still have any space in your show notes, I'll send you the link to that, where I take apart the Sculpt compiler
并展示了我们究竟是如何做到的。你说得完全正确。正是因为我们控制了编译器，我们才能将这种非常简单的同步逻辑转化为高度异步的 JavaScript。所以我可以总结一下，但真的去看看那个演讲，里面有所有的图表。编译器的工作方式是遍历它被给定的源代码。它将其分解成一个语法树。我们称之为抽象语法树。
and I show exactly how we did it. You're exactly right. It's because we control the compiler, we can turn this really simple synchronous logic into highly asynchronous JavaScript. So I can summarize it, but really go watch the talk for all the diagrams. But the way the compiler works is it walks over the source code it's been given. And it breaks that up into a tree of syntax. We call it an abstract syntax tree.
那包括诸如“这是一个函数定义，这个函数内部有这三条语句，其中一条是函数调用，另一条是赋值，另一条是返回”之类的内容。你最终会得到一个语言中的事物树，比如赋值、函数调用、函数定义、if 语句等等。
And that's things like, well, this is a function definition. This function has these three statements inside them. And one of them is a function call and the other one's an assignment and the other one's a return. And you end up with this tree of things in your language, like assignments, function calls, function definitions, if statements, and so on.
然后还有另一个阶段，即编译阶段，它遍历该抽象语法树，吐出编译后的表示形式。在 Sculpt 的例子中，那就是吐出 JavaScript。因为我们控制了那个编译阶段，我们可以说，实际上，每次你调用一个函数时，就调用一个函数。如果该函数发出信号说它被阻塞了，即它在等待某些东西，那么就暂停所有执行并等待直到它返回。然后当来自服务器的函数调用结果返回时，恢复执行，回到我们之前的位置，嵌套在无论多少层函数调用中，
And then there's another stage, which is the compile stage, which walks over that abstract syntax tree, spitting out the compiled representation. In Sculpt's case, that's spitting out JavaScript. And because we control that compile phase, we can say, actually, every time you're calling a function, call a function. And if that function signals that it's blocked, that it's waiting for something, then suspend all execution and wait until it gets back. And then when the result from that function call returns from the server, restore, go back to where we were, nested inside however many function calls
并恢复执行。因为我们控制了编译器，我们可以保存你所有的局部变量、堆栈上的函数等等，并恢复它。这真的很酷。去看看那个演讲。酷。是的，这很有道理。
and resume execution. And because we control the compiler, we can save all your local variables, what functions were on the stack and so on and resume it. It's really, really cool. Watch the talk. Cool. Yeah, that makes sense.
是的，我认为这是一个非常强大的模型。你知道，它让我想起了一点 Protocol Buffers 和 gRPC，在那里你可以，这实际上也支持跨语言，但即使只关注 Python，你知道，你会用这种 IDL 定义你的服务器调用。然后它会为你打包所有的参数等等。我认为 gRPC 和 Protocol Buffers 的问题在于，一直自动生成所有这些代码真是太痛苦了。所以 Anvil 避免了那个非常混乱的步骤。此外，你必须安装 Protocol Buffers，现在有了 Chocolatey 之类的一些东西，
Yeah, I think this is a really powerful model. You know, it's, it reminds me a little bit of like protocol buffers and gRPC, where you could kind of like, this actually supports cross language too, but even just focusing on, let's say Python, you know, you would kind of define your, your, you know, server calls in this sort of IDL. And then it would package all the arguments for you and all of that. I think about gRPC and protocol buffers is it's just, it's a huge pain to be, you know, auto generating all of this code all of the time. And so info kind of avoids that really messy step. Also, you have to get protocol buffers, which now with like Chocolatey and some of these things,
在 Windows 上还不错。在 Linux 上，你总是可以通过 apt-get 获取几乎任何东西。但是，仅仅拥有 Protocol Buffers 运行时和编译器，并将它们放入你的代码中等等，确实增加了巨大的开销。绝对是这样。我想这是另一个例子，你知道，那是谷歌，一家非常大的公司。
it's not too bad on Windows. On Linux, you can always apt-get just about anything. But yeah, just having the protocol buffers runtime and compiler and putting it in your code and all of that, it just adds a huge amount of overhead. Absolutely. I suppose that's another example of something, you know, that's Google, a very big company.
一个演示，即 HTTP 请求实际上并不是在谷歌内部传输东西的有效方式。谷歌一旦可以，就会把所有东西从 HTTP 转换成 Protocol Buffers，因为 Web 并不适合所有规模。这不是一个好的答案。Web 是“一刀切，一刀都不切”。是的，没错。它不适合那些超大规模的用途，而且对初学者非常不友好。总之，你可以看出，这是一个我一直在兜圈子的抱怨。
A demonstration like HTTP requests aren't actually a helpful way of transmitting stuff around inside Google. And Google turns everything from HTTP into protocol buffers as soon as they can because the web, it doesn't fit any size. It's not a great answer. One size fits none is the web. Yeah, that's right. Like it's not a good fit for those hyperscaler uses and it's really hostile to beginners. Anyway, you can tell that like, this is a rant I just keep sort of circling back to.
是的，所以关于这一点其实有一个问题，我的意思是，我不会说 Web 擅长什么，而是说生态系统在组件方面确实非常强大，真正的粘性价值在哪里。如果我需要一个非常好的日历组件，我几乎可以在 NPM 上找到任何东西。在 npm 上，对吧？所以会有一群人想要在类似 React 的东西中做客户端，也就是设计部分。有没有一种方法可以，比如在 Anvil 中做业务逻辑，这会不会让你容易受到我们之前讨论的问题的影响？好吧，所以很明显，如果你想
Yeah, so actually one question about this, I mean, what the, I wouldn't say what the web is good at, but what the, let's say the ecosystem is really, really powerful at and what the real sticking value is in the components. So if I need a really nice calendar component, I can find just about anything on NPM. on npm right and so there's going to be you know an audience of people who want to do the the client you know the design part in something like react is there sort of a way to do maybe like the business logic in anvil and and does that does that then make you susceptible to the problem we talked about earlier right well so obviously if so obviously, if you want to
使用 JavaScript 中更底层、更粗糙的东西，你就要付出在 JavaScript 中做事的代价，但我们不想阻止你。实际上，这是另一个重点。Anvil 是一个抽象。它获取复杂的东西——Web，并给你一种简单的方法来操作它。抽象的问题在于它们并不总是完全匹配底层现实。例如，每个抽象都会像这样失败。谷歌称之为“有漏洞的抽象”。每个抽象都会触及它的边缘，然后失败。我想到的是那种网站，但他们试图让它看起来像一个
use something lower level and gritty in JavaScript, you're going to pay the price of doing something in JavaScript, but we don't want to stop you. And actually, this is another big point. Anvil is an abstraction. It takes something complicated, the web, and it gives you an easy way to manipulate it. And the problem with abstractions is that they don't always exactly match the underlying reality. And for example, every abstraction fails like this. Google leaky abstractions. Every abstraction kind of reaches its edges and it fails. I'm thinking of those, the thing where it's a website, but they tried to make it look like an
应用程序。我想是 Cordera 之类的，但这些看起来总是很糟糕，对吧？所以是的，我考虑的是比那更高的层面。任何时候你拿一个东西并试图为它做一个更简单的抽象，那个抽象都会有局限性。Anvil 的 Python API 不会覆盖浏览器能做的每一寸地方。我的意思是，浏览器是一个令人难以置信的巨大平台。这根本不可能发生。所以我们不会锁定你并说，“好吧，太糟糕了，你现在用的是 Anvil，你不能使用任何那些 JavaScript 的好处。”
app. I think it's Cordera or something, but these always look terrible, right? So yeah, I'm thinking at a higher level than that. Anytime you take something and you try to make a simpler abstraction for it, there are going to be limits to that abstraction. Anvils, Python APIs are not going to cover every square inch of what the browser can do. I mean, the browser is a mind-bogglingly huge platform. It's just not going to happen. And so rather than lock you in and say, well, tough, you're using Anvil now. You can't use any of that JavaScript goodness.
我们到处都有“逃生舱”。我在不同的语境下已经谈到了其中一个。Uplink 就是一个逃生舱。无服务器计算很棒。这意味着你不需要托管任何东西，但我这里有一台物理计算机，上面有一个物理显卡，我运行着 Jupyter Notebook，我想就在这里运行我的代码，而不是在你们云端的某个地方。好吧，没关系。我们有一个逃生舱，说“没问题，你可以在你的电脑上运行代码，你可以把它插入到你的应用程序中，它和我们的无服务器代码一样好”。同样地，我们也有使用 HTML 和 JavaScript 的逃生舱。所以如果你有一个你非常想用的时髦日历组件，它比 Anvil 内置的日历小部件更适合你的
We have escape hatches everywhere. I've already talked about one of them in a different context. The uplink is an escape hatch. Serverless computing is great. It means you don't have to host anything, but I have a Jupyter notebook sitting here on my physical computer with a physical graphics card in it, and I want to run my code right here, not somewhere off in your cloud. Well, that's okay. We have an escape hatch that says, that's fine. You can run your code right there on your computer and you can plug it into your app and it's just as good as our serverless code. And in the same way, we have escape hatches to use things in HTML and JavaScript. So if you have a funky calendar component that you really want to use, it's better for your
用途。你可以做的是降级到 HTML 和 JavaScript。你可以从 Python 驱动那个 JavaScript。然后，这是最酷的部分，你之后不会被困在 JavaScript 中。你可以做的是从 Python 驱动那个日历组件，然后你可以把它定义为一个自定义组件。所以你包含了这个日历小部件的 Anvil 表单，你可以说“作为自定义组件使用”。然后你可以拿走你的应用程序并说“使这个应用程序作为依赖项可用”。现在你或任何其他人可以在他们自己的 Anvil 应用程序中，将你的应用程序添加为依赖项，然后进入拖放编辑器中的工具箱，
uses than the Anvil's built-in calendar widget. What you can do is you can drop down to HTML and JavaScript. You can drive that JavaScript from Python. And then, and here's the cool part, you're not stuck in JavaScript thereafter. What you can do is you could drive that calendar component from Python, and then you can define that as a custom component. So the Anvil form in which you've included this calendar widget, you can say, use as custom component. And then you can take your app and say, make this app as available as a dependency. And now you or anybody else can, in their own Anvil applications, add your app as a dependency and into the toolbox in the
在 Anvil 内置的按钮和日期选择器旁边，就会有你的日历小部件。其他人可以把它拖放到屏幕上。你可以在你的 Python 类中定义属性和事件。因为记住，你创建的表单只是一个 Python 类。所以你可以定义属性和事件，这样它就像任何其他 Anvil 组件一样工作。所以你拿走了这块外部 JavaScript，把它包装成一个易于使用的 Python 类，然后就可以被使用，直接插入到其他人的 Python 代码中，甚至拖放编辑器里。所以是的，我们非常执着于为
drag and drop editor alongside Anvil's built-in buttons and date pickers and so on will be your calendar widget. And somebody else can drag and drop it onto the screen. And you can define the properties and the events in your Python class. Because remember, the form you've created is just a Python class. And so you can define properties and events so it behaves like any other Anvil component. And so you've taken this piece of external JavaScript, you've wrapped it up as an easy to use Python class that can then be used, slotted right into other people's Python code, and even the drag and drop editor. So yes, we are religious about making escape hatches for
我们的平台无法完全覆盖的地方制作逃生舱。实际上，有一个很酷的例子。我们在 2020 年圣诞节前夕录制这个节目。我们正在做一个圣诞倒计时，每天一个 Web 应用程序直到圣诞节。我们几天前做的是一棵 3D 圣诞树。那棵 3D 圣诞树是使用 Three.js 构建的。我们在 Anvil 中没有原生的 3D 支持，但这没关系，因为你可以从 anvil.js.window.import3 导入，你实际上可以从 Python 驱动 Three.js JavaScript API，因为我们有那个桥梁。然后你可以把它包装起来，作为拖放组件在其他地方使用。这很有道理。这能和 Webpack 很好地配合吗？可能不行，对吧？那会是……你会做的事情是使用 Webpack 生成你的 JavaScript，然后你会
anywhere where our platform doesn't quite eke it out. And actually, there's a cool example of this. We're recording this just before Christmas 2020. And we're doing an advent calendar of a web app every day till Christmas. And the one we did a couple of days ago was a 3D Christmas tree. And that 3D Christmas tree is built using 3.js. We don't have native 3D support in Anvil, but that's okay because you can go from anvil.js.window.import3, and you can actually drive the 3JS JavaScript API from Python because we've got that bridge. And then you can wrap it up and use it as a drag and drop component somewhere else. That makes sense. Does this play well with Webpack? Probably not, right? That would be... The thing you would do would be you'd use Webpack to generate your JavaScript and then you would
导入那个 JavaScript。在那一点上，你将降级到 JavaScript 并与那些模块进行接口交互。然后你会做通往 Python 的桥梁。就像你必须编写那个桥梁一样。如果你想降级到像 JavaScript 这样的底层技术，你必须，你知道，在某个时候沾染一些 JavaScript。对。对。我们关心的是，我们不会强迫你也把应用程序的其余部分拖入 JavaScript。是的，这完全有道理。但是，我不太了解 Webpack。我以为它会
import that JavaScript. At that point, you'd be dropping down to JavaScript interfacing with those modules. And then you would do the bridge to Python. Like you're going to have to write that bridge. If you want to drop down to the low level technologies like JavaScript, you're going to have to, you know, to get some JavaScript on you at some point. Right. Right. The thing that we're concerned about is that we don't force you to drag the rest of your app into JavaScript as well. Yeah, that totally makes sense. But like, does it, I don't know too much about Webpack. I assumed it would kind
把所有的名字和一切都搞乱。答案是你告诉 Webpack 你的公共 API，所以 Webpack 知道哪些名字不能混淆。例如，对于 Three.js，所有这些内部的东西都会被混淆。当然，它会被压缩。但你正在使用的实际 API，比如“创建这个网格”、“在这里渲染这个”，这些名字保持不变，以便它们可以使用。同样，你这样做的方式和任何其他 JavaScript 程序员一样，因为这正是任何其他 JavaScript 程序员与这些库交互的方式。是的，完全有道理。所以是的，这太棒了。我的意思是，外面的每个人都应该尝试一下。有很多正在使用 Python 的人。我的意思是，那是推荐人们入门的语言。看到有一个
of mangle all the names and everything. The answer is that you tell Webpack your public APIs, and so Webpack knows which names not to mangle. So for example, with 3ds, all this internal stuff is going to be mangled. Sure, it's going to be minified. But the actual APIs you're using, like create this mesh, render this here, those names remain unmangled so that they can be used. Again, you do it just how any other JavaScript programmer would, because that's exactly how any other JavaScript programmer interacts with these libraries. Yeah, totally makes sense. So yeah, this is awesome. I mean, everyone out there should try this out. There's a lot of people who are using Python. I mean, that's the language I recommend people kind of get started with. And it's really cool to see that there's a
方法来，你知道，Patrick 和我总是告诉人们“使用它”。好吧，实际上这与我们的建议完美契合，之前的建议相当精神分裂，即“学习 Python 并构建一个网站”。这就是我们会告诉人们的。构建网站很容易。你不需要编写安装程序，但你应该学习 Python，而且不要告诉我们你打算同时做这些事情。而这一集实际上在我们建议了 11 年左右之后，终于补全了我们的建议。好吧，我的意思是，问题是你不是唯一给出那个建议的人，因为当你面对一个……好吧，我的意思是，你不是唯一给出那个建议的人，因为当你面对一个刚开始编程的人时，使用 Python 绝对是正确的建议。
way to, you know, Patrick and I always tell people like use it. Well, actually this, this fits in perfectly with our advice, which before was pretty schizophrenic, which was, you know, learn Python and build a website. That's what we would tell people. It's easy to build a website. You don't have to write an installer, but you should learn Python and don't tell us how you're going to do those things at the same time. And this episode actually completes our advice for once after, what, 11 years or something. Well, I mean, the thing is you're not the only people giving that advice because like when you are facing someone who? Well, I mean, the thing is, you're not the only people giving that advice because when you're facing someone who's just starting to program, use Python is absolutely the right advice.
你绝对不希望他们做的第一件事就是接触未受保护的 JavaScript、HTML 和 DOM。他们会尖叫着跑掉。但是的，没错。这就是每个人开始的地方。而 Web 应用程序是每个人都想完成的地方。还有“内裤地精”理论，比如第一步，学习 Python。第二步，问号，问号，问号。第三步，构建一个 Web 应用程序是每个人都想完成的地方。还有“内裤地精”理论，比如第一步，
You do not want the first thing they do to be exposed to unshielded JavaScript and HTML and DOM. They'll run away screaming. But yes, exactly. That's where everyone starts. And a web app is where everyone wants to finish. And there's the underpants gnomes, like step one, learn Python. Step two, question mark, question mark, question mark. Step three, build a web app is where everyone wants to finish. And there's the underpants gnomes, like step one,
学习 Python。第二步，问号，问号，问号。第三步，构建一个 Web 应用程序。而架起这座桥梁正是我们所做的。所以与此相关，因为这实际上是关于让构建 Web 应用程序变得更容易访问。而“可访问”在这里有两个含义，真的。因为，当然，如果你有一些困难和复杂的东西，你想做的事情就是让它变得足够简单，让新手能够上手。绝对地，如果我走到街上问三个人，“可访问性”意味着什么？他们可能会那样说。但这只是其中的一半。因为如果你只是试图让某样东西变得简单，你制造出来的就像是一个儿童游戏围栏。你制造出了一些
learn Python. Step two, question mark, question mark, question mark. Step three, build a web app. And bridging that is explicitly what we're about. So tangentially related to this, because what this is really about is making building web applications more accessible. And accessible has two meanings here, really. Because, of course, if you have something that is difficult and complicated, the thing you want to do is to make it easy enough for novices to pick up. And absolutely, if I went out onto the street and asked three people, what would accessibility mean? That's probably what they'd say. But that's only half of it. Because if you just try to make something easy, what you make is like it's a children's playpen. You make something that
类似玩具的东西。这会对你的用户造成伤害，原因有两个。我的意思是，第一，那些刚开始的人，他们只是刚开始，他们还没有完成，他们需要空间来增长他们的能力。如果他们被困在儿童区，那么他们就无法成长。这对他们来说是一个巨大的伤害。但这也会对世界其他地方造成伤害，因为仅仅因为我能编写五种不同的编程语言和五种不同的框架来构建 Web 应用程序，并不意味着我想这样做。也不意味着我公司里的其他人想等我去做。所以要真正做到可访问，你必须对新手足够简单，对经验丰富的专业人士足够强大，因为这就是
is kind of a toy. And that does your users a disservice for two reasons. I mean, one, it's that the people who are just starting, they are just starting, they're not finished yet, and they need room to grow their powers. And if they're stuck in the kiddie section, then they can't grow. And that is doing them a massive disservice. But it also does a disservice to the rest of the world because just because I can write five different programming languages and five different frameworks to build a web app doesn't mean I want to. And it doesn't mean that anybody else in my company wants to wait for me to do it either. And so to be properly accessible, you have to be simple enough for novices and powerful enough for seasoned professionals because that's
你给新手成长空间的方式，也是你真正为专业人士解决问题而不是只为初学者解决问题的方式，因为专业人士也有问题。是的，这完全有道理。是的，嗯，所以一个问题有点不同，比如是什么启发了你，你知道，你给我们一点点不同。是什么启发了你？给我们一点关于你自己的背景。这是一项巨大的工程。是什么启发了你说“我们要这样做”？我的意思是，你可以告诉我，但这至少有，我知道，几个人几年的努力。
how you give the novices space to grow and that's how you actually solve problems for the professionals rather than only solving problems for beginners because professionals have problems too yeah that totally makes sense yeah um so one kind of question is a little bit different like what inspired you you know you give us a little bit different. What inspired you? Give us a little bit of background on yourself. This is an enormous undertaking. And what inspired you to say, we're going to do this? I mean, you could tell me, but there's got to be at least, I know, several people years worth of effort here.
是什么启发了你真正下定决心构建这个？所以我的个人背景是我在那个年代用 QBasic 开始编程。我在学习时使用了像 Visual Basic 这样的工具。这很棒，因为这意味着我可以构建看起来像系统上其他任何东西的真实应用程序，无论是在 DOS 中，它看起来像任何其他 DOS 程序，还是在 Windows 中，它有窗口、按钮和菜单等等。这就是我进入编程的原因。我有一个大学老朋友叫 Ian，他的经历非常相似。我们最终，我通过生物学绕了一段路，因为我已经知道我足够热爱计算机，它们总会出现在我的生活中，所以我可以去大学做一些其他有趣的事情。
And what inspired you to really buckle down and build this? So my personal background is I started programming with QBasic back in the day. And I came up using these tools like Visual Basic as I was learning. And it was great because it meant that I could build real applications that looked like everything else on your system, whether that was in DOS, it looked like any other DOS program, or whether it was on Windows, it had Windows and buttons and menus and so on. And that is what got me into programming. And I have an old university friend called Ian, and he came up very much the same way. And we ended up, I took a detour via biology because I already knew I loved computers enough that they would always be somewhere in my life so I could go do something else that was fun
但我最终回家并攻读了博士学位，专注于构建可用的编程系统。Ian 实际上就在隔壁的研究小组，也在研究人机交互。他有完全相同的经历。他也通过用烙铁焊接东西来构建 Visual Basic 程序。他动手能力比我强得多。如果你有两个拥有那种专业知识的人，这与专业知识无关。是拥有那种经验的人，知道它有多简单，并让他们看着 Web。会有很多关于谁的抱怨，
at university. But I eventually came home and did a PhD focusing on building usable programming systems. And Ian was actually in the research group next door, also working on human-computer interaction. And he has exactly the same experience. He also came up building things in Visual Basic, tinkering stuff together with soldering irons. He's much better with his hands than I am. And if you have two people doing with that sort of professional expertise, it's not about the professional expertise. It's people with that experience, people who knew how simple it was and get them looking at the web. There's going to be a lot of ranting about who,
比如这个真正不可用的编程系统是怎么产生的。而且，你知道，拥有博士学位只是意味着我们有花哨的词汇来表达这些抱怨，但我们本来就会有这些抱怨。在某个时刻，我们只是说，“好吧，我们对此抱怨太多了。有人应该为 Web 构建
like how this really unusable programming system possibly came to be. And, you know, having PhDs in it just means that we have the fancy vocabulary in which to phrase those rants, but like we would have given those rants. And at a certain point, we just said, well, like we complain about this so much. Somebody should just build
类似 Visual Basic 或 Delphi 的东西。它会解决很多问题。”而且，你知道，我仍然把我在某个下午发给 Ian 的 Google Hangouts 消息像琥珀一样封存着，说“这是一个真正应该发生的事情”。只得到了像全大写的“是的”。所以，太棒了。这就是它的开始。就像，一旦我们知道这是我们可以做的事情，我们就不能不做。是的，这很有道理。所以你在某个时候是一名软件工程师，你亲眼看到了这有多痛苦。你是如何迈出那一步去……
something like Visual Basic or Delphi for the web. It would solve so many problems. And like, I still have sort of trapped in amber, the Google Hangouts message I sent to Ian, like one, you know, one afternoon saying, this is a thing that really should happen. Just got like, yes, in all capitals. And so like, amazing. That's how it started. It was like, once we knew it was a thing that we could do, we couldn't not do it. Yeah, that makes sense. So you were at some point a software engineer and you saw firsthand how painful this was. And how did you sort of make that leap to...
所以实际上，好吧，让我退一步。你是全职做 Anvil 吗？哦，是的。这就像，它最初是一个和朋友的项目。现在，你知道，它是一家有九个人的初创公司，并且发展得很好。非常感谢。而且盈利，所有那些有趣的事情。是的。
So actually, well, let me step back. Are you doing Anvil full time? Oh, yeah. This is like, it started as a project with a friend. Like it's now, you know, a startup with nine people and growing nicely. Thank you very much. And profitable and all that fun. Yeah.
所以你是如何迈出那一步的？我的意思是，这真是一个信仰的飞跃，对吧？去说“我要辞掉我的日常工作，我们要构建 Anvil”。显然事后看来，它进行得非常顺利，但你是如何鼓起勇气去那样做的？所以我确实认为，身处这个行业，我们最大的特权之一就是它比许多其他人所需要的勇气要少。我有朋友是专业演员。那是巨大的勇气。他们没有安全网在工作。从根本上说，如果结果证明没有人对 Anvil 感兴趣，
And so how did you take that leap? I mean, it's such a leap of faith, right? To say, I'm going to quit my day job and we're going to build Anvil. And obviously in hindsight, it's going amazing, but how did you kind of muster up the courage to go do that? So I do think one of our greatest privileges being in this industry is that there was less courage than it would have required for many other people. I have friends who are professional actors. That was huge courage. They're working without a net. Fundamentally, if it has turned out that nobody would have been interested in Anvil,
我可以去敲一堆雇主的门，很快就能找到工作。而所有这些损失都只是少赚了一点钱。我确实认为……我不确定“勇气”是否完全涵盖了它，或者也许是“风险”没有涵盖它。当时我正在做合同工。Ian 在这里剑桥的计算机实验室做博士后。所以我们已经，就像我们会见面并致力于项目，对“是的，这可能是一件真实的事情”感到越来越兴奋，所以最终我们开始，你知道，我们减少到每周工作四天，然后三天，因为你知道，因为我们可以兼职工作，因为你知道，我们年轻，刚从博士毕业，没有太多的生活开支，嗯，然后我们最终只是想，“好吧，这可能足够好了，看看世界怎么想。”
I could have come and knocked on the door of a bunch of employers and got a job fairly soon. And all that would have been would be a bit of missed earnings. I do think that the... I'm not sure courage quite covers it, or maybe it's risk doesn't cover it. As it was, I was contracting at the time. Ian was working as a postdoc at the computer laboratory here in Cambridge. And so we already, like we would meet up and work on projects in got more and more excited about yes this could be a real thing and so eventually we started you know we we went down to like four and then three days a week because you know because we could work part-time because you know we were young fresh out of phds not a lot of living expenses um and then we eventually just thought well this is probably good enough uh to see what the world thinks.
我们把它发到了 Reddit 上。Reddit 简直是抢着要。我们说，“啊，好吧，对了。人们确实对这个东西感兴趣。我们不是在想象它。”好吧，是时候跳进去了。所以我们把自己提升到全职。而且我们只是，我认为我们很幸运，因为我们在这样一个行业工作，我们有积蓄。
And we put it up on Reddit. And Reddit just sort of bit our hand off. And we went, ah, okay, right. People really are interested in this thing. We weren't imagining it. Okay, well, time to jump in. And so we cranked ourselves up to full time. And we were just, I think we were lucky because we worked in this industry that we had the savings.
我们有能力去兼职工作并建立业务，直到它能支持我们。是的，这完全有道理。是的，我认为这很棒。是的，关于 Reddit 的部分也真的引起了共鸣。我认为很多人应该更受鼓励去展示东西。我认为很多人很害怕。我记得我在大学时，我有一些非常糟糕的副项目。所以我想，如果你们谷歌我的名字，有一些，我不记得是 Reddit 还是某个论坛，但有一些论坛
We had the ability to go to part-time work and build up the business until it could support us. Yeah, that totally makes sense. Yeah, I think that's great. Yeah, the part about Reddit too really resonates. I think one thing a lot of people should be more encouraged to show things off. I think a lot of people are afraid. I remember when I was in university, I had some some side projects that were terrible. And so I think I think if you Google my name, there's there's some I don't remember if it's Reddit or some forum, but there's some forum
帖子，我介绍了一些事后看来绝对糟糕的游戏引擎。它被彻底撕碎了，但它，我从那次经历中学到了很多。直到今天，我的意思是，我们在 Hacker News 上发布了关于 Eternal Terminal 的消息，所有这些。而且我认为，你知道，身处这些社区实际上是我们之前没有提到的事情，但这是我认为初学者真的应该做的另一件事，就是让自己参与到其中一些……Eternal Terminal 是你，那是
posts where I introduced some game engine that was in hindsight, absolutely terrible. And it got completely torn up, but it was, I learned so much, you know, from that experience. And to this day, I mean, we posted about eternal terminal on, on hacker news and all of that. And I think, you know, being in those communities is actually something we didn't mention earlier, but that's another thing that I think beginners really should do is, is get kind of uh you know get yourself enrolled in some of these some of these uh eternal terminal is you that's
太棒了，我没意识到这一点。太棒了，很高兴见到你。这真是一项很酷的技术。酷。是的，我正在考虑完全取代 SSH，这会，你知道，会增加更多东西，但是，很多人，最大的抱怨是你必须打开另一个 TCP 端口。所以是的，看看它会走向何方。太棒了。但无论如何，是的。我看到了它，因为你把它发布出来了。是的，我的意思是，我们老实说，我们应该早一年把 Anvil 发布出来，可能。是的。是的。有道理。是的。我认为这很难做到，因为你觉得，“哦，如果我留下了糟糕的第一印象”，但从来没有人说，“我发布得太早了，我放弃了它”。你总是听到相反方向的事情。我确实认为任何不想相信这一点的人都会相信他们的情况很特殊。我认为 Anvil 有点特殊，因为它是一个开发工具。
awesome i didn't realize that awesome really pleased to meet you it's a really cool technology cool yeah i'm thinking about replacing ssh entirely which would you know it would be adding a lot more to it but uh a lot of people, the biggest complaint is that you have to open another TCP port. So yeah, we'll see where it goes. Awesome. But anyway, yes. And I saw it because you put it out there. And yes, I mean, we honestly, we should have put Anvil out there like a year sooner, probably. Yeah. Yeah. Makes sense. Yeah. I think it's hard to do because you feel like, oh, if I make a bad first impression, but no one ever says, I put it out too early and I gave up on it. You always hear things in the other direction. I do think anyone who wants not to believe that will believe that their case is special. I think Anvil is a little bit special because it's a development tool.
而一个开发工具要么对一切都有用，要么对什么都没用。所以我们在所有这些领域都必须达到一个最低水平。我的意思是，Anvil 是一个巨大的平台。我的意思是，我们还没有触及表面之下的很多东西，但它是一个无服务器应用程序托管环境。它是一个拖放设计器。它是一个 Python 中的基于 Web 的 UI 工具包。它是一个 Python 到 JavaScript 的编译器。
And a development tool is kind of useful for everything or useful for nothing. And so there was a minimum level that we had to get it to in all of these areas. I mean, Anvil is a massive platform. I mean, we haven't touched on a lot of the stuff underneath the surface, but it's a serverless app hosting environment. It's a drag and drop designer. It's a web-based UI toolkit in Python. It's a Python to JavaScript compiler.
它就像现成的用户身份验证。它集成了 Google API、Facebook、Microsoft 等等，Stripe，你知道，它是一个任务调度器，因为当然，你必须能够在你的应用程序中运行计划任务，它有 Uplink，它有，我的意思是，我肯定漏掉了一些东西，我们对这个有愿景，这是我们想要的最终状态，这就是一个理想的平台看起来的样子。它将拥有所有这些能力，并且如此简单。我们一直在衡量我们所拥有的和它可能成为或将成为的样子之间的差距。相反，我们应该衡量我们所拥有的和人们已经在挣扎的事情之间的差距，因为那会使它更快地推向市场。这是一个，你知道，非常好的观点，实际上，整个，你知道，记录和捕捉人们想要的东西。我觉得我们迫切需要做一个关于这个的节目。你知道，你构建了一些东西，我们所有人，当我们构建东西时，我们构建它
It's like off-the-shelf user authentication. It's got integration into Google APIs, Facebookis facebook microsoft what have you stripe uh you know it's a task scheduler because of course you've got to be able to run scheduled tasks in your apps it's got the uplink it's got i mean i'm sure i'm missing stuff out and we had this vision for this is like this is the end state we wanted to be this is what an ideal platform would look like it would have all this power and be this simple. And we kept measuring the difference between what we had and what it could be or would be. And instead, we should have been measuring the difference between what we had and what people were struggling with already, because that would have got it out the door a lot faster. That is, you know, such a good point, actually, the whole, you know, logging and capturing what people want. I feel like we desperately need to do a show on this. You know, you build something, all of us, when we build things, we build it
最终是为了其他人，因为，如果有一千个人要使用你的程序，其中 999 个不是你，对吧？所以你是在为其他人构建一个应用程序，并且你对他们想要什么做了很多假设，对吧？所以例如，对于 Eternal Terminal 的第一个版本，它有一种方法，它基本上减慢了内容的交付速度，以便你可以按 Ctrl+C。所以如果你搞砸了，你知道，试图 cat 一个二进制文件之类的，你仍然可以退出。但后来发现人们根本不想要那个。而且有一堆问题，一大群人对此感到不满或抱怨。所以我把它去掉了，人们高兴多了，但它，这只是很多试错，以及倾听问题和反馈。
ultimately for other people, because there's, if a thousand people are going to use your program, 999 of them aren't you, right? And so you're building an app for other people and you're making a lot of assumptions about what they want, right? So for example, for Eternal Terminal in the first versions, it had a way of, it basically slowed down the delivery of contents that you could hit control C. So if you goofed up and, you know, tried to cat a binary file or something, you could still punch out. But then it turns out people just didn't want that. And there was just a bunch of issues, people, a whole bunch of people were upset about it or complaining about it. And so I took it out and people were much happier, but it's, it was just a lot of kind of trial and error and listening to issues and feedback.
而且真的没有任何分析。我的意思是，没有任何东西从 Eternal Terminal 反馈回来。而且我认为这是一个巨大的错失机会，因为有很多事情我们必须通过艰难的方式来学习。这是运行托管服务的一个巨大优势。而且那是，我的意思是，众多优势之一。这也意味着你可以升级，你可以发布升级，并且你可以非常快地发布回滚。
And there really wasn't any analytics. I mean, there's nothing that reports back from Eternal Terminal. And I think that that is such a missed opportunity because there's just so many things that we have to learn the hard way. That is a huge advantage of running a hosted service. And that's, I mean, one of the many advantages. It also means you can upgrade, you can ship upgrades, and you can ship rollbacks very quickly.
顺便说一下，我应该提到，作为托管服务也有缺点。如果你想，“哦，是的，这会很棒，但我不可能依赖别人的托管服务来做那个”，我们已经为你覆盖了，别担心。答案是 pip install anvil app server。所有的 anvil app server，所有的 anvil 运行时东西实际上都是开源的，所以你可以，你可以自托管一个应用程序，你可以
I should mention, by the way, that there are disadvantages to being a hosted service as well. And if you think, oh, yes, this would be great, but I couldn't possibly rely on someone else's hosted services for that, we've got you covered, don't worry. The answer is pip install anvil app server. All of the anvil app server all of the anvil runtime stuff is actually open source so you can just you can self-host an app you can
事实上，你可以在文本编辑器中构建一个应用程序并自托管它，如果你真的想的话，根本不需要接触任何属于我们的东西。但否则，你可以在 Anvil 中构建，然后你可以直接从我们的存储库中 git clone 到你的磁盘上，然后在本地托管它。但是的，所以本地的东西很重要。而且我猜 Eternal Terminal 是那种想要成为本地应用程序的东西。而像 Anvil 这样的东西想要成为托管应用程序。因为同样，这都是关于逃生舱的。你想要有逃生舱，以便有人说，
in fact you can build an app in a text editor and self-host it and never touch anything owned by us at all if you really want to but otherwise you can build an anvil and then you can just get clone it out of our repository onto your disk and then host it locally. But yeah, so local stuff is important. And I guess Eternal Terminal is one of those things that kind of, that wants to be a local application. And something like Anvil kind of wants to be a hosted application. Because again, it's all about the escape hatches. You want to have the escape hatch so that someone who says,
“哦，我正在树莓派上运行这个。我在电视台工作。如果互联网断了，我们需要能够继续广播，这必须在建筑物里的一台电脑上运行。”真实故事。没关系。你可以那样做。但 95% 的用例是，我不想担心服务器。我不想担心托管。我只想点击一个按钮，让它在那里。所以 Anvil 如果你想解决我们正在解决的问题，自然会倾向于成为一个托管服务。而像 Eternal Terminal 这样的东西倾向于成为某种东西
oh, I'm running this on a Raspberry Pi. I work at a TV station. We need to be able to carry on broadcasting if the internet goes down, this has to be running on a computer in the building. True story. That's fine. You can do that. But the 95% use case is, I don't want to worry about servers. I don't want to worry about hosting. I just want to click a button and have it there. And so Anvil kind of naturally gravitates to being a hosted service if you want to solve the problems that we're solving. Whereas something like Eternal Terminal gravitates to being something
哦，我是在树莓派上运行这个程序的。我在一家电视台工作。我们需要确保在互联网中断的情况下也能继续广播，所以它必须在楼里的一台电脑上运行。这是真实的故事。没问题，你可以这样做。但95%的使用场景是，我不想操心服务器，也不想操心托管。我只想点击一个按钮，它就能运行。因此，如果你想解决我们正在解决的问题，Anvil自然会倾向于成为一种托管服务。而像Eternal Terminal这样的东西则倾向于成为一种
that's running on your own computer. And I think people's perceptions about telemetry change drastically because it's impossible to interact with a hosted service without creating logs and i mean we ah yeah that makes sense we are very privacy conscious with logs uh check out our
这在您自己的电脑上运行。我认为人们对遥测技术的看法发生了巨大变化，因为如果不创建日志，就不可能与托管服务进行交互，我的意思是，我们，啊，是的，这很有道理，我们在日志方面非常有隐私意识，呃，看看我们的
expectations for a downloaded program is somewhat different, I think. Yeah, it totally makes sense. Yeah. I mean, in any case, you need to be very diligent about anonymization and you're really trying to look for macro trends. Everyone who creates the button widget in Anvil, do they create it once and then never again? That would be a sign that either there's something wrong with it or people just were discontent with it. And creating that basic telemetry in a way that preserves people's privacy, I mean, that could easily be a whole show. I mean, there's a lot of content there. Yeah, we started. So part of the starting anvil story I kind of elided is that when it was just the two of us, we were getting started, we actually, we were able to work out
我认为，对下载程序的期望有所不同。是的，这完全说得通。我的意思是，无论如何，您都需要非常谨慎地进行匿名化处理，并且您确实是在试图寻找宏观趋势。每个在 Anvil 中创建按钮小部件的人，他们是创建一次就再也不用了吗？那将是一个信号，要么是它有问题，要么是人们对它不满意。以保护人们隐私的方式创建这种基本遥测技术，我的意思是，这很容易成为一整期节目。我的意思是，那里有很多内容。是的，我们开始了。所以，我省略了 Anvil 起步故事的一部分，那就是当我们只有两个人时，我们刚开始，实际上，我们能够
of an office in the computer lab, which is Cambridge's computer science department. And one of the real benefits of that is being able to just walk down the corridor and, you know, ask people in the security research group about problems like this. And that's something that was really valuable to us. Yeah. Yeah. That's awesome. I think that was good. I think the, yeah, basically the nutshell is, and I don't know if there's good sort of standardized libraries for this. I mean, I know there's, there's like segment and some of these things for, for collecting analytics on the web, but I don't know if there's sort of standardized libraries for this. I mean, I know there's like Segment and some of these things for collecting analytics on the web, but I don't know if there's sort of something generic there. But yeah, basically, you know,
在计算机实验室的一间办公室里工作，那是剑桥大学的计算机科学系。这样做的一个真正好处是能够直接走到走廊里，你知道，向安全研究小组的人询问这样的问题。这对我们来说非常有价值。是的。是的。太棒了。我认为这很好。我认为，是的，基本上核心内容是，我不知道是否有好的标准化库来做这件事。我的意思是，我知道有像 Segment 这样的一些东西，用于在网络上收集分析数据，但我不知道是否有某种标准化库。我的意思是，我知道有像 Segment 这样的一些东西，用于在网络上收集分析数据，但我不知道是否有某种通用的东西。但是，是的，基本上，你知道，
you want to try and get some kind of feedback to improve your app and pay attention to all the issues and all of that. I guess that's the sort of mantra. Yeah, I think that's fair to say. Hey, everybody. We have a new sponsor, and that is ConfigCat. And I'm going to tell you a little bit about what ConfigCat is.
您想尝试获得某种反馈来改进您的应用程序，并关注所有问题等等。我想这就是所谓的口头禅。是的，我认为这样说是公平的。嘿，大家好。我们有一位新的赞助商，那就是 ConfigCat。我将向您介绍一下 ConfigCat 是什么。
It is a feature flag service. You can easily use flags in your code with ConfigCat libraries for Python, nine other platforms. Toggle your feature flags visually on the visual dashboard. Hide or expose features in your application without redeploying your code. Set targeting rules to allow you to control who has access to those new features.
它是一项功能标志服务。您可以使用 ConfigCat 的 Python 库以及其他九个平台的库，轻松地在代码中使用标志。在可视化仪表板上直观地切换您的功能标志。无需重新部署代码即可隐藏或展示应用程序中的功能。设置定位规则，让您可以控制谁有权访问这些新功能。
ConfigCat allows you to get the features out faster, test in production, and do easy rollbacks. With ConfigCat's simple API and clear documentation, you'll have initial proof of concept up and running in just minutes. Train new team members in minutes easily so you don't have to pay extra for growing teams. With a simple UI, the whole team can use it effectively. Whether you're an individual or a team, you can try it out with the forever free plan.
ConfigCat 让您能够更快地发布功能、在生产环境中进行测试并轻松回滚。凭借 ConfigCat 简单的 API 和清晰的文档，您只需几分钟即可完成初步的概念验证并运行起来。轻松在几分钟内培训新团队成员，因此您不必为不断壮大的团队支付额外费用。凭借简单的用户界面，整个团队都可以有效地使用它。无论您是个人还是团队，都可以通过永久免费计划进行尝试。
Release your features faster and with less risk with ConfigCat. Check them out today at ConfigCat. Check them out today at configcat.com. Cool. Yeah. For people who don't know what feature flags are, it's, you know, imagine you have something out in production and you want to change some kind of behavior. So you might say, you know, now use this other database, but then you do that and then it's broken and now you've broken it for everybody. And that's, that's kind of a nightmare. nightmare. So what you want to do instead is you want to try something out on like a few people and then slowly kind of add more and more and more people.
以更低的风险更快地发布您的功能，使用 ConfigCat。今天就去 ConfigCat 看看吧。今天就去 configcat.com 看看吧。酷。是的。对于那些不知道什么是功能标志的人来说，你知道，想象一下你在生产环境中发布了一些东西，并且你想改变某种行为。所以你可能会说，你知道，现在使用这个其他数据库，但然后你做了，结果它坏了，现在你把它弄坏了，对每个人来说都是这样。这，这简直是一场噩梦。噩梦。所以你想要做的是，你想要在少数人身上尝试一下，然后慢慢地增加越来越多的人。
And one way to do that is to have a feature flag, have a flag that says, if this is part of my test group of people, then switch to the new database, otherwise use the old database. And slowly like that if becomes true for more and more people. And so ConfigCast is a service that kind of handles a lot of that for you. So they can like handle deciding like who gets the feature and who doesn't. And then you can go in
实现这一目标的一种方法是拥有一个功能标志，有一个标志说，如果这是我的测试组人员的一部分，那么切换到新数据库，否则使用旧数据库。就这样，如果对于越来越多的人来说，它变为真。所以 ConfigCat 是一项为您处理很多此类事务的服务。所以他们可以处理决定谁获得该功能，谁没有。然后你可以进入
their UI and change all of that and slowly, slowly get it to 100%. And they take a lot of that burden off you. So check them out. They're great. Yeah. So let's dive into the company. So is the company called Anvil? Oh, the company is called the Tuesday Project Limited because Ian and I used to work on Tuesday and we had agreed many, many, many years ago that if a startup ever came out of this, it had to be called the Tuesday Project. And so it is. The Tuesday Project. Very cool. So does the Tuesday Project have internships? There's a lot of folks listening who are in the process of trying to find a place to intern at or find a place to work at. So the wonderful thing about living on a startup's timeline is that if you're recording an episode that's going to air in three months time,
他们的用户界面并更改所有这些，慢慢地，慢慢地将其提高到 100%。他们为您减轻了很大负担。所以去看看他们吧。他们很棒。是的。那么让我们深入了解一下这家公司。公司叫 Anvil 吗？哦，公司叫 Tuesday Project Limited，因为 Ian 和我过去在 Tuesday 工作，我们很多很多年前就商定，如果从中诞生了一家初创公司，它必须叫 Tuesday Project。所以它就是。Tuesday Project。太酷了。那么 Tuesday Project 有实习机会吗？有很多听众正在寻找实习的地方或寻找工作的地方。所以生活在初创公司的时间线上的一件美妙的事情是，如果你正在录制一集将在三个月后播出的节目，
I genuinely don't know exactly what the state of our hiring is going to be at that point. But I would strongly encourage anybody who's interested to sign up. Anvil is free to use. It's a premium. If you sign up for a free account, then you get a banner on the top of your apps and basically that's it. If you sign up for an account and if you're on our mailing list, we will mail you when we are hiring. So that is the eternally true thing that we are expanding. We are growing nicely and very happy about it. So if you are based in the UK and you are interested in fixing web development and being part of the team that does that, then do hop along and sign up for an account. You can also go to anvil.works slash jobs. And if we have a hiring window open at that point, then you'll see that.
我真的不知道到那时我们的招聘状况会是什么样。但我强烈鼓励任何感兴趣的人注册。Anvil 可以免费使用。它是免费增值的。如果你注册一个免费账户，那么你的应用程序顶部会有一个横幅，基本上就是这样。如果你注册了一个账户，并且如果你在我们的邮件列表中，我们会在招聘时给你发邮件。所以这是一个永恒的事实，我们正在扩张。我们发展得很好，对此非常高兴。所以如果你在英国，并且你有兴趣修复网络开发并成为实现这一目标的团队的一员，那么请加入并注册一个账户。你也可以访问 anvil.works/jobs。如果那时我们有招聘窗口，那么你就会看到。
Otherwise, sign up for an account, we'll let you know. Yeah. And so what's a day in the life of... Actually, how many people work on Anvil? You said it's about nine people? This is, again, one of those pieces of information that's likely to go out of date very quickly. But yes, there's currently nine of us. We're entirely bootstrapped. So we have not at this stage taken any venture investment. We are funded entirely by happy customers, which is a really great place to be from the perspective of one's blood pressure level heading into a global pandemic, for example. Oh my goodness.
否则，注册一个账户，我们会通知你。是的。那么……的一天是什么样的？实际上，有多少人在 Anvil 工作？你说大约有九个人？这又是那种很可能很快就会过时的信息。但是的，目前我们有九个人。我们完全是自力更生的。所以在这个阶段，我们没有接受任何风险投资。我们完全由满意的客户资助，从一个人在面对全球大流行病时的血压水平来看，这是一个非常好的位置。天哪。
Yeah. Turned out to be fine, actually. It turns out that a massive change of working causes a whole bunch of people to need to build new processes really, really quickly. Yeah. view processes really, really quickly. Yeah, actually, you know, well, so yeah, maybe a bit of a bit of a tangent, but what is your take on, you know, venture capital, specifically around things like developer tools? I feel like in that area, I mean, I'll give you my take up front, and then we could talk about it. I feel like the market is not really known well. And so it's not clear.
是的。实际上结果证明没问题。事实证明，工作方式的巨大改变导致一大群人需要非常非常快地建立新的流程。是的，视图流程非常非常快。是的，实际上，你知道，好吧，所以是的，也许有点跑题了，但你对风险投资有什么看法，特别是围绕开发者工具之类的东西？我觉得在那个领域，我的意思是，我会先告诉你我的看法，然后我们可以讨论一下。我觉得市场并不是很出名。所以不清楚。
Some of the venture capitalists want, they have really, really big ambitions. And so for developer tools that might, going to venture capitalists might be a mistake because the market might just not be that big and then you'll end up in kind of a bad spot. Yeah, I don't think insufficient market size is our problem. There are just shy, I think, of 10 million Python developers out there. And many, if not most of the rest also do web
一些风险投资家想要，他们有非常非常大的野心。所以对于开发者工具来说，去找风险投资家可能是一个错误，因为市场可能根本没有那么大，然后你最终会陷入一种糟糕的境地。是的，我不认为市场规模不足是我们的问题。那里有将近 1000 万 Python 开发人员。而且其余的大多数（如果不是全部）也做网络
development. So I think we're fairly comfortable that the problem we're solving is sufficiently huge. I think it changes your distribution of outcomes. Taking investment can also really help you if you are not as lucky as Ian and I were, and you're not able to slow burn work on this part-time until it's something that's ready to show to the world and start selling. I'm not religious about this. I don't think that venture capital is a bad thing, even for development tools. Although I think the VC ecosystem writ large has swung and missed a few times on models for developer tools, and some of them have been more successful than others. I would say MongoDB was a win, Docker was a miss, despite the fact that
开发。所以我认为我们相当确信我们正在解决的问题足够巨大。我认为这改变了你的结果分布。如果你不像 Ian 和我那么幸运，并且你无法在兼职工作直到它准备好向世界展示并开始销售之前缓慢地进行这项工作，那么接受投资也可以真正帮助你。我对此并不迷信。我不认为风险投资是一件坏事，即使对于开发工具也是如此。尽管我认为整个风险投资生态系统在开发工具模型上已经摇摆不定并错失了几次机会，其中一些比其他一些更成功。我会说 MongoDB 是一个赢家，Docker 是一个失败者，尽管事实上
Docker has completely transformed its target market. It's, yeah, heralds of open source business models there. Yeah, I think Kubernetes kind of took all the actual economic value. Yeah, I mean, well, this is, okay, tangent to the tangent. Yeah, it's true. Okay, This is a reason that developer tools are difficult. If you're starting a company and you are thinking about releasing your company's main product as open source, and developers basically demand that at some level for a lot of the tools that they will take seriously, you have to answer the question of, what do I do now I've given my whole product away for free?
Docker 已经完全改变了它的目标市场。它是，是的，开源商业模式的先驱。是的，我认为 Kubernetes 占据了所有实际的经济价值。是的，我的意思是，好吧，这是，好吧，跑题的跑题。是的，这是真的。好吧，这是开发者工具困难的一个原因。如果你正在创办一家公司，并且你正在考虑将公司的主要产品作为开源发布，而开发人员基本上在某种程度上要求他们认真对待的许多工具都这样做，你必须回答这个问题：既然我已经把我的整个产品免费送出去了，我现在该怎么办？
Somebody once, I'm blanking on his name, once said to me that if you open source, you no longer have a product. You have two products. You have one you sell and one you give away and make sure the one that you're selling is actually worth something. This has actually worked out really well for us because we do have the two products. We have the Anvil runtime for running your applications and we have the editor for building them. And so we have open sourced the runtime and we still have something that is worth people paying for premium features on. But I do think that from the last few
有人曾经，我忘了他的名字，曾经对我说，如果你开源，你就没有产品了。你有两个产品。你有一个卖的，一个送人的，并确保你卖的那个确实值钱。这对我们来说实际上非常有效，因为我们确实有两个产品。我们有用于运行应用程序的 Anvil 运行时，我们有用于构建它们的编辑器。所以我们开源了运行时，我们仍然有值得人们为高级功能付费的东西。但我确实认为，从过去几年
years, we can take the lesson that if you are infrastructure that will be built on top of, you'd better have a really good story for why the fate of Docker is not going to apply to you. Yeah, that's really well said. Rewinding, where were we before the tangents? Oh, yeah. So, okay. So we were talking a little bit about VCs. And then I think the question I was going to lead into is, what is it like to work on Anvil? Like, you know, I mean, okay, we can talk pre-COVID, right?
来看，我们可以吸取教训，如果你是将被构建在其之上的基础设施，你最好有一个非常好的故事，说明为什么 Docker 的命运不会发生在你身上。是的，说得真好。倒带，我们在跑题之前在哪里？哦，是的。所以，好吧。所以我们刚才谈论了一点关于风险投资的事情。然后我想我准备引入的问题是，在 Anvil 工作是什么感觉？就像，你知道，我的意思是，好吧，我们可以谈谈 COVID 之前，对吧？
So, you know, how is it different than, you know, people have this vision, especially folks in maybe university, have this vision, you know, you come into the office, there's a bunch of cubicles. Everyone just sits down. No one talks to each other. You just write code. You all go home. It's sort of like the office space kind of model, right? And so one of the things we try to do is ask people, what is unique about the sort of work environment and sort of the workplace that you've set up and just,
所以，你知道，它与，你知道，人们有这种愿景，特别是在大学里的人，有这种愿景，你知道，你走进办公室，有一堆隔间。每个人都坐下来。没有人互相交谈。你只是写代码。你们都回家了。这有点像办公空间那种模式，对吧？所以我们尝试做的一件事是问人们，你们建立的工作环境和工作场所的独特之处是什么，只是，
you know, make it a little human, you know, for folks out there. To be clear, we are in the middle of a pandemic. We are working entirely from home. I desperately miss the office because I really like the people I work with. And I like being there to hang out and have lunch with them and have interesting conversations. I think something that is, I suppose, two things that make this company to be a particularly fun one in terms of how much I enjoy being around the people is that because we make tools for developers, everybody in the company writes code. Whether they are showing people how to use Anvil
你知道，让它变得有点人性化，你知道，为了外面的人。需要明确的是，我们正处于大流行之中。我们完全在家工作。我非常想念办公室，因为我真的很喜欢和我一起工作的人。我喜欢在那里和他们一起闲逛、吃午饭并进行有趣的对话。我认为有些事情是，我想，两件事使这家公司成为一个特别有趣的公司，就我有多喜欢和这些人在一起而言，因为我们为开发人员制作工具，公司里的每个人都写代码。无论他们是在向人们展示如何使用 Anvil
or working on the core product or both, everybody is writing code. And so everybody, we sort of speak the same language and we all understand like at a sort of deep visceral level, the problems we're solving and what isn't a good solution. And so it's really great fun. You know, we pull everybody from the, you know, CEO to the newest developer advocates into the design meetings. And that's really, that part is really fun. Yeah, I think it's great that you all can speak the same language because at my job,
还是在核心产品上工作，或者两者兼而有之，每个人都在写代码。所以每个人，我们有点说同一种语言，我们都在一种深刻的直觉层面上理解我们正在解决的问题以及什么不是一个好的解决方案。所以这真的很有趣。你知道，我们把每个人，从首席执行官到最新的开发者倡导者，都拉进设计会议。这真的很有趣。是的，我认为你们都能说同一种语言真是太好了，因为在我的工作中，
half of us are speaking JavaScript, half are speaking C++. It's just, it's just the best. Well, and we all speak Python. Of course, I mean, a bunch of our team speak JavaScript because we build the Anvil editor and the runtime, which means that we spend an awful lot of time, honestly, pounding our head against the desk and saying, when some corner of JavaScript or browsers or HTTP bites us, we bash our heads against the desk and say, I am doing this so that hundreds or
我们一半人在说 JavaScript，一半人在说 C++。这简直是，这简直是最好的。好吧，我们都说 Python。当然，我的意思是，我们的团队中有一群人说 JavaScript，因为我们构建了 Anvil 编辑器和运行时，这意味着我们花了很多时间，老实说，对着桌子敲打我们的头，说，当 JavaScript 或浏览器或 HTTP 的某个角落咬我们时，我们对着桌子敲打我们的头，说，我这样做是为了让成百上千
thousands of other people won't have to for whatever little feature we're working on. So yeah, that part's really great in that kind of alignment. I think also, kind of because Python has a... Both Python, the language, and the problem domain we're looking at, and the sorts of people who are likely to know a little bit of Python, but not much else, and they are firmly within our sort of targets, means that we get to interact with a really interesting variety of people. So talked about, you know, people who arrived in a steaming hurry having to build something. The microbiological diagnostic unit in Melbourne, in Australia, suddenly sometime around the beginning of 2020 acquired a really, really, really urgent need for a system they can just
或成千上万的其他人在我们正在处理的任何小功能上都不必这样做。所以是的，那部分在那种一致性方面真的很棒。我认为也，有点因为 Python 有一个……无论是 Python 这种语言，还是我们正在研究的问题领域，以及那些可能懂一点 Python 但除此之外什么都不懂的人，他们坚定地在我们的目标之内，这意味着我们有机会与各种各样非常有趣的人互动。所以谈到了，你知道，那些匆匆忙忙赶来必须构建某些东西的人。澳大利亚墨尔本的微生物诊断部门，在 2020 年初的某个时候，突然产生了一个非常非常非常紧迫的需求，需要一个系统，他们可以
toss gene sequences of viruses into and have it be a genetic tree of like okay that sequence matches something that came from the other end of australia check you know where did that person come in check that flight trace it to other people you know uh are our infection control measures in school working like all of this really really cool stuff and i got to end i got to talk to this bioinformaticist uh at the mdu about like how are people doing tracing in the in the pandemic and like you know what is what does he use python for what you know what tools is he building you know how does their how has their work been changed by the fact that it's all just sequence it and now it's all data science you know it's not so much bench biology it's toss it all into the sequencer and throw python at it is now how they
把病毒的基因序列扔进去，让它成为一个遗传树，比如，好的，那个序列匹配了来自澳大利亚另一端的东西，检查，你知道，那个人是从哪里进来的，检查那个航班，追踪到其他人，你知道，呃，我们在学校的感染控制措施有效吗，所有这些非常非常酷的东西，我得，我得和 MDU 的这位生物信息学家谈谈，关于人们在疫情中是如何进行追踪的，以及，你知道，他用 Python 做什么，你知道，他正在构建什么工具，你知道，他们的工作是如何因为现在全是测序而改变的，现在全是数据科学，你知道，这不是太多的台式生物学，而是把所有东西扔进测序仪，然后把 Python 扔给它，现在就是他们
how that lab works and like that's one example of thousands where people are doing interesting things that aren't you know that they're a little bit off the beaten track. Because if you build something that enables the people who are, for whom building a web app wasn't accessible, if you make it accessible, just a bit more accessible, you will suddenly pull in all these people who are doing all sorts of non-traditional things and you will meet them and you will have a great time doing so. You also get to pull in like non-traditional stuff and you will meet them and you will have a great time doing so you also get to pull in like non-traditional stuff so you know we have everybody from like uh one of our uh developers who's sadly just gone on on maternity leave i mean you know great news for her uh sad for uh sad for us she's great uh just switched careers from financial services because she reckoned that
那个实验室是如何工作的，这只是成千上万个例子中的一个，人们正在做一些有趣的、不是你知道的、有点偏离常规的事情。因为如果你构建了一些东西，使那些原本无法构建 Web 应用程序的人能够构建，如果你使它变得可访问，稍微更容易访问一点，你就会突然吸引所有这些正在做各种非传统事情的人，你就会见到他们，并且你会玩得很开心。你还可以吸引像非传统的东西，你就会见到他们，并且你会玩得很开心，你还可以吸引像非传统的东西，所以你知道，我们有每个人，比如呃，我们的一位开发人员，她很遗憾刚刚去休产假了，我的意思是，你知道，对她来说是个好消息，呃，对我们来说很悲伤，呃，对我们来说很悲伤，她很棒，呃，刚刚从金融服务业转行，因为她认为
programming was more fun. And we hired her, I think like six, nine months out of bootcamp. And she hadn't really written Python before she got to us. And that's actually great. We love hiring people like that because those people are our customers, right? She really deeply understands what it's like to be starting out on Python and web development because that was her very, very recently. And now she gets to be at the leading edge of building the developer tool that solves that problem for everybody else. Yeah, that's awesome. Yeah, I think that would be so fascinating to meet the people who are,
编程更有趣。我们雇用了她，我想是在训练营结束后六、九个月。她在来到我们这里之前并没有真正写过 Python。这实际上很好。我们喜欢雇用这样的人，因为这些人是我们的客户，对吧？她非常深刻地理解刚开始学习 Python 和 Web 开发是什么感觉，因为那是她非常、非常近期的经历。现在她有机会站在构建解决所有人这个问题的开发工具的最前沿。是的，太棒了。是的，我认为见到那些人会非常迷人，
you know, because it's like the people who already have a website, they have that inertia, right? They would have to, you know, even using the things we talked about earlier, they still would have to deconstruct to some degree their website. But it's the people who are just starting
你知道，因为就像那些已经有网站的人，他们有那种惯性，对吧？他们必须，你知道，即使使用我们之前谈到的东西，他们仍然必须在某种程度上解构他们的网站。但正是那些刚刚开始的人
who are looking starting who are looking at this whole ecosystem and saying, okay, you know, where should my first line of code go? And so, you know, a place like Anvil gets a lot of those people. And I think that could be so exciting to see the next generation of web developers, right? I think that's awesome. Absolutely. You said like the number of people who type Python, Python, GUI into Google, and then keep typing variations on that because they've learned some Python. Everything so far has been really straightforward.
正在看着整个生态系统并说，好的，你知道，我的第一行代码应该去哪里？所以，你知道，像 Anvil 这样的地方会吸引很多这样的人。我认为看到下一代 Web 开发人员会非常令人兴奋，对吧？我认为这太棒了。绝对。你说过，比如在 Google 上输入 Python、Python、GUI 的人数，然后不断输入它的变体，因为他们学了一些 Python。到目前为止，一切都非常简单。
This next step, there must be a way that's this straightforward for the next step, right? It can't possibly be this difficult. Yeah. What about for desktop? Do you have an integration with Electron or something like that? We don't. It's something that people have periodically talked about. It hasn't risen to the top of our list.
这下一步，一定有一种方法对下一步来说是这么简单的，对吧？它不可能这么困难。是的。桌面端怎么样？你有与 Electron 或类似东西的集成吗？我们没有。这是人们不时谈论的事情。它还没有上升到我们列表的顶部。
It's not like the thing that most affects people. Going back to these people it's awesome to meet, I will take the opportunity I've resisted so far to plug our podcast because what we do is... Oh, go for it. About once a month, we get on a phone call with somebody who does something really cool and talk to them about what they do so we've had like interviews with like tv broadcast engineers because you know it turns out they were they
它不像最影响人们的事情。回到这些很棒的见面的人，我将借此机会插播我们的播客，因为我们做的是……哦，去吧。大约一个月一次，我们和做一些非常酷的事情的人通电话，和他们谈谈他们做什么，所以我们采访过像电视广播工程师这样的人，因为你知道，事实证明他们
shifting shifting to broadcasting over the internet they needed to completely rebuild the system that you know when you when you're like when your satellite box isn't working and you call up the customer service center and they go sort of tap, tap, tap, tap, tap. Ah, yes, sir. It appears that that thing, it can't reach the Wi-Fi. So, you know, let's move it to a better place with better signal. That whole system that collects and presents those diagnostics needed to be rebuilt because they were shifting to internet streaming. And, you know, the great Anvil story in this is that a TV broadcast engineer, who's not a web developer, was able to pick up and plug a web front end into the backend systems that run their TV broadcasts really easily without having to learn five different programming
转向通过互联网广播，他们需要完全重建系统，你知道，当你，当你像，当你的卫星盒不工作时，你打电话给客户服务中心，他们去，比如，敲，敲，敲，敲，敲。啊，是的，先生。看来那个东西，它连不上 Wi-Fi。所以，你知道，让我们把它移到一个信号更好的地方。那个收集并呈现这些诊断信息的整个系统需要重建，因为他们正在转向互联网流媒体。而且，你知道，这里面伟大的 Anvil 故事是，一位电视广播工程师，他不是 Web 开发人员，能够非常容易地拿起并插入一个 Web 前端到运行他们电视广播的后端系统，而不必学习五种不同的编程
languages. But the really fun story for us is that I then got to interview him and I got to learn about how TV broadcasting works, which is something like I hadn't encountered in a million years. Yeah, the real programmers, right? The ones who are setting up the program for tomorrow's show. Yeah, absolutely. So yes, it is really, really, really great meeting this huge variety of people who do all sorts of stuff. It's really fun. Yeah, this is awesome. So how are ways that people can kind of get a hold of you and get a hold of or learn more about Anvil? Right. Well, the first thing to do is to go to anvil.works and hit the build link because it's free to use. We have a bunch of tutorials. Try it out and see what we mean about how our development ought to be. So that's the first one. If you want
语言。但对我们来说真正有趣的故事是，我随后有机会采访了他，我了解了电视广播是如何工作的，这是我一百万年来从未遇到过的事情。是的，真正的程序员，对吧？那些正在为明天的节目设置程序的人。是的，绝对。所以是的，见到这些做各种各样事情的各种各样的人真的非常、非常、非常好。这真的很有趣。是的，这太棒了。那么人们可以通过什么方式联系你并联系或了解更多关于 Anvil 的信息？好的。好吧，第一件事是去 anvil.works 并点击构建链接，因为它是免费使用的。我们有一堆教程。试一试，看看我们所说的开发应该是什么样子。所以这是第一个。如果你想
to find me, I am Meredydd on Twitter. That's M-E-R-E-D-Y-D-D. You probably want to click the link in the show notes for that one. What nationality is that? Is that Irish? Welsh. Oh, Welsh. Okay, got it. Welsh is one of these languages. It's like Polish. It's 100% completely phonetic, but you show the letters on the page to an English person and they make the most amazing face. Yeah. Cool. I think, so this is going to show my total ignorance of geography here, but Welsh is, it's Southwest, right? Of the whole UK. Yes, Wales is on the Southwestern end of the UK. Most people who live there speak English,
找到我，我是 Twitter 上的 Meredydd。那是 M-E-R-E-D-Y-D-D。你可能想点击节目说明中的链接。那是哪个国籍？那是爱尔兰人吗？威尔士人。哦，威尔士人。好的，明白了。威尔士语是这些语言之一。它就像波兰语。它是 100% 完全拼音的，但你把页面上的字母展示给一个英国人看，他们会做出最惊人的表情。是的。酷。我想，所以这会显示我在这里对地理的完全无知，但威尔士是，它是西南，对吧？整个英国的。是的，威尔士位于英国的西南端。大多数住在那里的人说英语，
but a lot of them are also bilingual in Welsh. And that includes my family. Oh, very cool. I feel like I've slightly earned the right to make everyone suffer through spelling my name. Yeah, that's right. Yeah, I think, yeah, we'll definitely put links to the show notes and everything. And so, you know, definitely check out, you know, anvil.works. Oh, one thing we didn't cover that I want to circle back to really quick
但他们中的许多人也是威尔士语的双语者。这包括我的家人。哦，非常酷。我觉得我稍微赢得了让每个人都忍受拼写我名字的权利。是的，没错。是的，我想，是的，我们肯定会把链接放到节目说明和所有东西里。所以，你知道，一定要看看，你知道，anvil.works。哦，有一件事我们没有涵盖，我想很快回过头来
is, you know, especially for students, you know, what is free and then what costs money? Right. Okay. So what is free is pretty much everything I've talked about. So the design, the hosting, the serverless Python, the uplink, all of that stuff is free. If you're using a free account, there are two limitations. One is that you'll get a banner on the top of your app saying, made with Anvil. And the other is that there are going to be some limits to the libraries you can import in the serverless environment in your server modules. And this is just because we're hosting code from random strangers from the internet on our servers. So you're saying I can't train my neural network using your serverless functions and have you pay for it?
是，你知道，特别是对于学生，你知道，什么是免费的，然后什么是收费的？好的。所以免费的是我谈到的几乎所有东西。所以设计、托管、无服务器 Python、上行链路，所有这些东西都是免费的。如果你使用免费账户，有两个限制。一个是你的应用程序顶部会有一个横幅，上面写着“用 Anvil 制作”。另一个是你在无服务器环境中，在你的服务器模块中可以导入的库会有一些限制。这只是因为我们正在我们的服务器上托管来自互联网上随机陌生人的代码。所以你是说我不能使用你们的无服务器函数来训练我的神经网络，并让你们为此付费？
Correct. You can't train your neural network on our servers. But if you want to bring your notebook up and connect it to the uplink and train your neural network there, you can absolutely do that on the free plan. Oh, interesting. So yeah, the idea is you can do everything. And of course, you can use the open source app server, you know, wherever you are, whatever you're doing. So you can use everything in Anvil for free. What we do offer is paid plans that make life easier for you, that take some of the sting out of the hosting. If you want to run a neural network in the cloud without having to worry about, oh, this computer with a Jupyter notebook must stay up at all times, then you're welcome to
正确。你不能在我们的服务器上训练你的神经网络。但如果你想把你的笔记本拿上来并连接到上行链路并在那里训练你的神经网络，你绝对可以在免费计划上做到这一点。哦，有趣。所以是的，想法是你什么都可以做。当然，你可以使用开源应用程序服务器，你知道，无论你在哪里，无论你在做什么。所以你可以免费使用 Anvil 中的所有东西。我们提供的是付费计划，让你的生活更轻松，减轻托管的一些痛苦。如果你想在云中运行神经网络而不必担心，哦，这台带有 Jupyter 笔记本的电脑必须一直保持开启，那么欢迎你
take out a plan with us, that kind of thing. You work on a team, you want to collaborate with your colleagues, that kind of thing. We offer that. The goal is that anyone can use it. It's a real development tool. Rock up and give it a try. Something else I should mention, by the way, for all the educators listening, if you're using Anvil to teach a school or university course, all of the features are completely free. Just drop us a line at education at anvil.works. Oh, very cool. Good to know. Yeah, we'll have a lot of that. And we'll have students asking their teachers to do that. Absolutely. Well, bring it on. Cool. So what is the name of your podcast? Oh, Stories from the Workshop. You can get it at anvil.works slash podcast.
和我们一起制定一个计划，诸如此类。你在团队中工作，你想与同事协作，诸如此类。我们提供这些。目标是任何人都可以使用它。它是一个真正的开发工具。过来试一试。顺便说一句，我应该提到的另一件事是，对于所有正在收听的教育工作者，如果你正在使用 Anvil 来教授学校或大学课程，所有功能都是完全免费的。只需给我们发邮件至 education@anvil.works。哦，非常酷。很高兴知道。是的，我们会得到很多。我们会让学生要求他们的老师这样做。绝对。好吧，放马过来。酷。那么你的播客叫什么名字？哦，Stories from the Workshop。你可以在 anvil.works/podcast 上获得它。
Cool. Okay, so we'll have all of this in the show notes. We'll have Meredit's Twitter. We'll have Anvilworks links. So check out the show notes. If you're in your car or something, wait till you get home and then check out the show notes. But we'll have links to everything over there
酷。好的，所以我们会在节目说明中包含所有这些。我们会有 Meredydd 的 Twitter。我们会有 Anvilworks 链接。所以看看节目说明。如果你在车里或什么地方，等到你回家，然后看看节目说明。但我们会在那里提供所有东西的链接
and there's a ton of information. For folks out there, if you build anything with Anvil, even if it's your first Hello World, drop us a line, send us an email, programmingthrowdown at Gmail, send Meredith an email and come back to us. Yeah, we love to see that.
并且有大量的信息。对于外面的人，如果你用 Anvil 构建任何东西，即使是你的第一个 Hello World，给我们发个信息，给我们发封电子邮件，programmingthrowdown@gmail，给 Meredith 发封电子邮件，然后回到我们这里。是的，我们喜欢看到这一点。
It is so, so satisfying to see, hear stories from people and to see the things people have built. It really fills our bucket. So definitely don't hesitate to reach out. And again, if you are interested in Jobs, Careers, Internships stuff, again, sign up and just stay on our newsletter
看到、听到人们的故事并看到人们构建的东西是如此、如此令人满足。它真的填满了我们的桶。所以绝对不要犹豫，联系我们。再次，如果你对工作、职业、实习之类的东西感兴趣，再次，注册并留在我们的时事通讯上
and we will let you know if, as, and when we are next hiring yeah and in the meantime you'll go to check out these things like uh was it sculptor is that right the the python thing sculpt yeah yeah check out this technology if you want a survey of python in the browser stuff a colleague of mine actually gave a talk at pycon uk last year it was you know last year that conferences were a thing. So 2019, there's a webpage write-up we can also put in the show notes that's like comparing Sculpt and Brython
我们会让你知道我们下次什么时候招聘，是的，在此期间，你会去看看这些东西，比如，呃，是 Sculpt 吗，那是对的，那个 Python 的东西，Sculpt，是的，是的，如果你想调查浏览器中的 Python 东西，看看这个技术。我的一位同事实际上去年在 Pycon UK 做了一个演讲，那是，你知道，去年会议还是个东西的时候。所以 2019 年，有一个网页文章，我们也可以放在节目说明中，就像比较 Sculpt 和 Brython
and Transcript and PyAdide and PyPyJS and like why we chose what the choice, made the choices we did for Anvil. So you can go check that out as well. And please do a Sculpt project. We always love getting more contributors. So yes, check us out. Submit a PR. Yeah, I mean, there's no
以及 Transcript 和 Pyodide 和 PyPyJS，以及为什么我们选择了我们为 Anvil 所做的选择。所以你也可以去看看那个。请做一个 Sculpt 项目。我们总是喜欢获得更多的贡献者。所以是的，看看我们。提交一个 PR。是的，我的意思是，没有
better signal than I mean, the ideal interview is where someone just sits with your team for a week. That's my take on it. And so there's no better proxy for that than someone who contributes. I know personally we've hired people who have
比这更好的信号了，我的意思是，理想的面试是某人只是和你的团队坐在一起一周。这就是我的看法。所以没有比贡献者更好的代理了。我知道我个人雇用了
contributed to our open source projects. So I have firsthand experience with that. And yeah, it's super important. So I said that Bridget, one of our developers, just went on maternity leave. And her maternity leave cover, who has now been made permanent because he's so good, is somebody who was on our forums, contributing to stuff, maintaining open source Anvil components for other people to use. And so by the time it got to the point of hiring,
为我们的开源项目做出贡献的人。所以我对此有第一手的经验。而且是的，这超级重要。所以我说 Bridget，我们的开发人员之一，刚刚去休产假了。她的产假替补，现在因为他太优秀而被转为正式员工，是曾经在我们的论坛上，为东西做出贡献，维护开源 Anvil 组件供其他人使用的人。所以当到了招聘的时候，
we just sort of took a look at him and went, yeah, yes, yes, we definitely want to hire him. We have worked with him. We know exactly what he can do. Sold. So that's a really good routine. And yes, he was also contributing to Sculpt as well by the end of it.
我们只是看了他一眼，然后说，是的，是的，是的，我们绝对想雇用他。我们和他一起工作过。我们确切地知道他能做什么。成交。所以这是一个非常好的常规。而且是的，到最后他也为 Sculpt 做出了贡献。
He's a really good chap. Wow, very cool. Awesome. Hey, Meredith, this is amazing. I really, I'm super motivated to try this out. I actually have a project that I can try it out with even today. Promise me you'll send an email with the link.
他是一个非常好的人。哇，非常酷。太棒了。嘿，Meredydd，这太神奇了。我真的，我超级有动力去尝试一下。我实际上有一个项目，即使在今天也可以尝试一下。答应我你会发一封带有链接的电子邮件。
I really want to see it. I will actually, yeah. I'll definitely do that. I hope to share everyone the next sort of thing that I'm trying to cook up. And I think Anvil would be perfect for it. So thank you so much. I think that this taught me a lot. I think it taught the audience a lot about the web and about this new way of programming
我真的很想看到它。我实际上会，是的。我肯定会那样做。我希望与大家分享我正在尝试烹饪的下一件事。而且我认为 Anvil 对它来说是完美的。所以非常感谢你。我认为这教会了我很多。我认为它教会了听众很多关于 Web 和关于这种新的编程方式
for the web. So this is super exciting. I really appreciate you coming on. Well, I had a great time chatting to you. So thank you very much. Cool. Thanks a lot. And everyone out there, you know, thanks a lot for all of your support on Patreon and
为 Web。所以这超级令人兴奋。我真的很感谢你来。好吧，我和你聊天很开心。所以非常感谢你。酷。非常感谢。还有外面的每个人，你知道，非常感谢你们在 Patreon 上的所有支持，以及
by supporting us through our Audible subscriptions. And everyone stay safe out there. I think by the time this makes it to to the air maybe we'll have like the vaccine in many people's hands i really don't know it's all speculation at this point started dosing here in the uk and i cannot wait to get back in oh wow and hug people and get back in the office and you know stuff yeah exactly yeah well so everyone stay safe out there and we'll catch you next episode thanks very much. Music by Eric Fine-Mallory.
通过我们的 Audible 订阅支持我们。每个人在外面都要注意安全。我想当这播出的时候，也许我们会有像疫苗在许多人手中，我真的不知道，此时此刻全是猜测。在英国这里开始给药了，我迫不及待地想回去，哦哇，拥抱人们并回到办公室，你知道，诸如此类，是的，完全正确，是的，好吧，所以每个人在外面都要注意安全，我们下一集再见，非常感谢。音乐由 Eric Fine-Mallory 提供。
Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share-A-Like 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix and adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合和改编作品，但您必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。